Almost heaven, old or twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're older, everyone's moved on, but I remember twitch chat from those days that are gone, twitch emotes from long ago, made you feel you're not alone.
Bible Thump, Typing Dance Game, Forehead Swift Rage and Fail Fish, warum kann ich das auswendig?
Life was easy, spamming all the time, TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine, twitch emotes from long ago, made you feel you're not alone.
Kappa Porkchamp, Bunger Z, Singler, danke schön für den Sub.
From yesterday, yesterday, twitch emotes from long ago, made you feel you're not alone.
Pong is Pongchamp, Cap is Cap Bug, Bible Thump, Twitch emotes, Pepehands, Twitch emotes, Bible Thump, Twitch emotes.
Recycle Story
Ja, so sieht es aus, exzellent, exzellent, oder auch nicht, je nachdem, ja.
So, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben, nirgendswo, weil wir gerade erst angefangen, Null.
Äh, übrigens Leute, wisst ihr, was richtig Pains Champ ist, ich hab's ja auf Twitter
geschrieben.
Ich hab beim Umzug meinen N64 weggeschmissen, richtig, richtig, äh, richtig blöd gewesen.
Guckt mal, 2013, wo ich hierher umgezogen bin, hab ich mein komplett, das ganze, ich
hab ne Technikkiste gehabt, da war auch ein ganz alter PC und so noch drinne, äh, Pentium
2 oder so, ähm, den hab ich weggeschmissen, da war halt auch mal N64 schon mal eine Wii
drinne.
Und das bereue ich ja wirklich so ein bisschen, ich hätt mir das, äh, besser aufheben sollen.
Witzigerweise die Spiele hab ich aufgehoben, aber die Konsolen selbst hab ich nicht aufgehoben.
Was sind denn deutsche Twitter Trends heute wieder, oh je, wenn ich das schon seh, da
weiß ich, dass ich da nicht reingucken will.
Also wir haben, wir haben die üblichen, wir haben die üblichen, äh, Justice, äh, Social
Justice Warrior-Themen auf Twitter, dann haben wir Fußball und wir haben Fußball, na geil,
das ist ja das, was die, was die Welt gebraucht hat.
Da hab ich ja drauf gewartet, äh, Twitter Trends sind so Paynes-Champ, alter.
Kompletter Hyper, gibt es ein Hyper Paynes-Champ?
Hyper Paynes-Champ, gibt's da ein E-Mode?
Hat irgendjemand schon mal Hyper Paynes-Champ gemacht?
Nein, wie?
Was ist da los?
Also normalerweise auf jegliche dummen E-Modes, auf die ich komme, kam schon jemand anders,
aber Hyper Paynes-Champ anscheinend noch gar nicht.
Ich mein, Hyper Paynes-Champ wäre eigentlich ganz einfach, einfach den hier in rot machen
und, und, dass er wackelt, also im Prinzip so wie, im Prinzip so wie Hyper Gatchi.
Kann das sein, dass Hyper Gatchi gar nicht beaktiviert ist bei mir?
Ach nee, Gatchi Hyper heißt es bei mir, ah, alles klar, okay.
Gatchi ist ja auch Paynes-Champ-Hyper, nee, Wahnsinn, Big Brain E-Mode ausgedacht, lass
mal schnell machen.
Es ist ultra oft Impfkrams, naja nicht nur in den Trends, das ist halt ein Thema, was
die Leute beschäftigt, ne.
Ich hab jetzt gelesen, dass irgendwo in, ich glaube Niedersachsen oder so war das, dass
sie 2G machen wollten, auch für Supermärkte und dann hat irgendwie ein Gericht gesagt
ein paar Tage später, nee gibt's nicht, Anzeige ist raus.
Hast du über die Updates gehört, die Call of Duty 2.0 noch nicht was zerstört haben?
Hä?
Das Spiel lebt noch, das ist der vorvorletzte Teil, Call of Duty Spiele leben immer nur
ein Jahr, wenn's hochkommt, wie kann man Call of Duty von vor zwei Jahren zerstören?
Das ist schon zerstört, das hat sich selbst zerstört.
Ich hab meine Windows-Updates, oh nein, nein, hab ich nicht, übrigens, weil ich grad im
Chat lese New World, Leute ihr werdet's nicht glauben, New World hat, wo hab ich denn, hab
ich denn überhaupt noch offen, hier, New World hat einen riesen, riesen Spielerzuwachs von
2000 zu 9, nee von 18.000 zu 9, letzte Woche, wo wir geguckt haben, waren's glaub ich nur
100.000 und jetzt sind's 118.000, also die haben anscheinend irgendwelche Patches rausgebracht
um nicht zu vergessen, es ist halt Weihnachten, das ist normal, guck hier waren wir mal, das
ist halt Weihnachten, also im Prinzip, spätestens im Januar, wir dürfen's nicht vergessen,
die haben's geschafft zu droppen von 1.000.000 auf 100.000, ungefähr, oder von 900 auf 100.000
zu droppen in einer Zeit, wo die Leute eigentlich viel Zeit vorm Rechner verbringen und jetzt
noch Ferien sind, also die haben es eigentlich geschafft in einer Zeit zu verscheißen, in
der es gar nicht wirklich möglich ist es zu verscheißen, wenn man es nicht komplett
verscheißt, ihr wisst, ihr wisst wie ich mein, well done, ja, was ist deine Meinung
zu JetBrains Fleet, ist das Fleet, du meinst diesen Editor von denen, ich find das ist
ne gute Idee, es ist halt nicht auf Javascript Basis, es ist halt auf Java Basis, also Log4j,
wir kommen, ne es ist halt der JetBrains IDE Kern als Editor mit Plugins, finde ich ist
ne gute Sache, weil aktuell gibt es ja auch schon ein paar coole Plugins, zum Beispiel
das Rust Plugin für die JetBrains IDE's, aber du weißt nie genau welche du verwenden
sollst, aktuell hast du immer IntelliJ verwendet, wenn du nicht wusstest was du sonst verwenden
solltest, ich find das ist ne sehr gute Idee von denen, weil die haben nun mal die besten
IDE's, das einzige wo man sich drüber streiten kann ist ob vielleicht was Frontend Sachen
angeht, wo ich das Studio Code nicht angenehmer ist dank den ganzen Plugins die es gibt, aber
ansonsten wenn du für Go guckst, Go ist Go Land mit Abstand das beste, Rider ist mit
Abstand das beste, auch besser als Virtual Studio für, ne das glaub ich nicht, glaub
ich nicht, glaub da schlummert zu viel oller Kram drinne rum, für Java, ich hab ehrlich
gesagt keine Ahnung was Java angeht, aber was gibt es denn sonst noch für Java IDE's,
NetBeans gibt es noch, Eclipse gibt es noch, was gibt es denn sonst noch, ich hab keine
Ahnung was Java, was sind denn Java IDE's, was gibt es denn da so alles, so IntelliJ
ist doch eigentlich, ja Intelli davon red ich doch, das die gibt es ja klar, was gibt
es denn zusätzlich noch, so das ist auch das beste siehste, also im Prinzip haben
die wirklich, also welche Frage, äh was versteht einer hier gekaufte Alexa Englisch, achso
ich hab keine, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie da alles zusammen führen werden, das
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, ne glaub ich nicht, ich denk nicht, übrigens Battlefield
hat auch einen riesen Spieler Zuwachs von 30.000, 35.000 Spieler guck mal hier, aber wisst
ihr woran das liegt, es ist gerade kostenlos, es ist kostenlos und trotzdem will es keiner
spielen, das musst du erstmal schaffen, es ist kostenlos und es ist, ich hab hier mal,
ich kann ja mal kurz steam, matrix HD, Dankeschön für den Sub, oh ja, bei wieviel negativ
sind 33, oh es ist besser geworden Leute, ähm es ist free weekend, bis morgen noch,
es ist free weekend und falls irgendjemand das am free weekend gespielt hat und sich
gedacht hat, das will ich kaufen, kann das jetzt kaufen für einen 30% billiger oder
er geht in einen Keyshop seiner Wahl und kauft sich Battlefield für 20 Euro, was kostet
es denn gerade bei G2A, die machen wir mal in einem, wer weiß, hab keinen Bock mit dem
Polendrecker einzufangen, was kostet es denn hier gerade, Battlefield 2042, oh ja, da kostet
es noch weniger als auf Steam, aber es gibt es teilweise noch billiger, die werden ihre
Codes nicht los, ja, ne, mit deiner Grafikkarte kannst du es vergessen, das ist vorbei, von
wann ist denn das, 660 TI, von wann ist die denn, das muss ja noch vor der 780 gewesen
sein, das ist 2012 oder so, 2012, ey guck mal, gut geschätzt oder, das ist ja uralt, aber
hey sogar die Grafikkarte kannst du heute wahrscheinlich für 800 Euro verkaufen, wie
sieht es denn eigentlich aktuell so gerade aus, ne, 3090, RTX nicht GTX meine Güte,
wie sieht es aktuell so aus, wie, das ist doch G-Bate, das kann nicht sein, das stimmt
fast nicht, Stock X, das stimmt fast nicht Leute, das ist G-Bate, ach, das ist irgendeine,
das ist irgendeine Auktionsseite oder was, Preischamp, ne, Preischamp ist dead, der läuft
einfach nur noch, den schalte ich demnächst ab, ich hab keinen Bock mehr was daran zu machen,
hat jetzt seinen Purpose erfüllt oder auch nicht, das ist aber, das wäre ja fast schon
normaler Preis, das sind eher die Preise mit denen du hier rechnen musst, Alter, das ist
so teuer, wenn du dir mal überlegst, ne, du hast einen kompletten Rechner dafür bekommen
und gar keinen schlechten Rechner, also du hast für 2900 Euro hast du einen ziemlich
High-End Rechner bekommen, vor dieser ganzen Geschichte, das ist eigentlich mega krass,
wenn man sich das mal überlegt, Mining Machine, ach ja, das ist ja günstig, ein Schnapper,
ein Schnapper, guckt mal hier, der Bauer Gaming PC für 12.000 Euro, also so gerne ich mir
die Bauer YouTube, äh, sorry, die Aua, die Aua, die Aua YouTube Videos angucke, ähm,
es bringt mich aber nichts dazu eine 12.000 Euro Rechner zu kaufen, wir können uns alternativ
auch das Mining Rig kaufen, für, äh, für 22.000 Euro, was ist denn da drin, außer
dass es, dass eine 8 drauf ist, ist da, ah, ok, Wasserkühlung, naja gut, ja, pretested,
aber warum ist das so teuer, warum ist das so teuer, ich mein, ok, die Grafika hat ja
marktisch 3000 Euro Kosten, ok, ähm, das ist glaube ich noch nicht mal die beste CPU,
die es aktuell gibt, pretested 5,1, ok, ok, aber, aber nichts, aber nichts mal ansatzweise,
ach ja, Finanzierung für 1000 Euro im Monat, das ist ja, das ist ja auch, äh, großes
Entgegenkommen, das ist ja krass, was ich für einen Rechner bezahlen würde, das mache
ich davon abhängig, was das Zeug kostet, wenn ich mir einen neuen Rechner kaufen muss,
normalerweise habe ich immer so 2000 bis 3000 Euro bezahlt für einen neuen Rechner, also
wenn ich, wenn ich wirklich komplett, ähm, komplett gekauft habe und ich habe in den
letzten Jahren eigentlich fast immer mehr oder weniger komplett gekauft, das einzige,
was ich umgezogen habe oftmals war die SSD aus dem alten, neuen Rechner, ich habe mir
überhaupt keine, gar keine Arbeit mehr gemacht, den alten Rechner auszubauen aus dem alten
Gehäuse, ich habe das alte Gehäuse einfach genommen, SSD raus, eins zu eins auf den Dachboden
gestellt oder getauscht hier für einen Streaming-Vorschau-Rechner und, äh, deswegen bin ich ja auch auf diesen
Fractal Design, deswegen bin ich ja auch auf diesen Fractal Design Gehäusen hängen geblieben,
ich habe die letzten drei oder vier, vielleicht sogar fünf, äh, PC-Generationen diese Fractal
Design Gehäuse, mittlerweile das letzte, glaube ich, das R6, was ich habe, ich glaube, vom
R4 anfangend, hatte ich, hatte ich alle, haben die irgendwie, ne, siebener habe ich noch
nicht, ich habe noch einen sechser, glaube ich, ja, und ich habe mir immer die Gehäuse,
das geht, ich glaube, das kostet, was kosten das, gucken wir mal, das aktuelle, 117 Euro
und ich habe es mir auch immer mit Fenster nebendran gekauft, was total bescheuert war,
weil eigentlich sieht mein Rechner von innen ganz cool aus, ich habe RGB-RAM, ich habe
RGB am Lüfter, ich habe RGB an der Grafikkarte, das sieht wahrscheinlich echt ganz nice
aus, aber ich habe dann andere Rechner direkt vorm Fenster stehen, sodass ich nicht mal
mehr reingucken kann, also richtig hängen geblieben und ich habe damals sogar, richtig,
richtig, low brain, ich habe damals von Noctua sogar noch Lüfter Modding Platten gekauft,
gut, ich habe es mir damals irgendwie gerechtfertigt, indem ich gesagt habe, ja, ne Luftfluss wird
besser, das heißt, die übertaktete CPU wird besser gekühlt und sowas, was mir damals
eigentlich schon klar war, dass es kompletter Schwachsinn ist, wie heißen die denn, äh,
cooler Mod, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie diese Dinger heißen, hier, Chromax, genau, da habe
ich mir noch so, noch so komische Platten gekauft, um es auf den Lüfter zu machen,
dass es cooler aussieht und jetzt sieht es cool aus, ja, aber ich habe das Fenster vorm
Rechner zugestellt, ich kann nicht mal mehr reingucken, richtig, richtig Sixhead Time,
ich habe keine Ahnung, was das für ein Glas ist, zumindest ist das Gehäuse nice, ist sehr
geräumig, sehr stabil, hat Staubfilter, ich würde mir übrigens kein Gehäuse mal ohne
Staubfilter heutzutage holen, Staubfilter ist das beste, was es gibt, Leute, ich sag
es euch, Staubfilter ist massiv der Pog, Pogge, ist das, ohne Staubfilter geht nichts, ja,
die haben es halt richtig verkackt und die hier auch, na, so, ähm, was war man jetzt,
übrigens wisst ihr, was ich auch letztens auf YouTube gesehen habe, da will ich jetzt
aber, das will ich jetzt nicht zeigen, weil ich weiß, dass es ein etwas kontroverses
Thema ist, aber ich glaube, die eigentliche Sache, die daraus resultiert ist gar nicht
so kontrovers und zwar, ich habe ein Video gesehen, da hat irgendein bayerischer Politiker
war das, glaube ich, hat gemeint, sie wollen Telegram verbieten und da habe ich mir gedacht,
wie, warum, also, das Unreal 5, welches, welches, ja, ich habe mir das angeguckt, aber du meinst
ja sicherlich nicht das, welches meinst du, Stellenanzeigen, ja, ich habe gestern schon
aufgenommen, das, das will der Ministerpräsident von Sachsen, ja, ich habe keine Ahnung, was
mit dem los, also, die wollen, äh, ja, das habe ich schon gesehen, das habe ich gesehen,
das ist wirklich ziemlich poc, wobei ich halt davon ausgehe, dass der neue Matrix-Film nix
taugen wirkt, ganz ehrlich, die haben alle nix getaucht außer der erste und der erste
ist, finde ich, immer noch eines der besten Filme, die es gibt, die habe ich, das habe
ich bestimmt schon zehnmal geguckt oder so, das war es mit Cold, Cold, Cold Fusion, nein,
was ist da, naja, zumindest, zumindest, angeblich, angeblich hat irgendjemand vorgeschlagen,
wir könnten doch, also, habe ich ein Video gesehen, hier bei diesen üblichen Corona,
Coronanachrichten, dass man Telegram sperren will und das passt nur auf, warum man Telegram
sperren will, weil die Leute hate-speaken und, ähm, was haben sie gesagt, hate-speak und
Hass verbreiten in Telegram, dann dachte ich mir so, ok, was genau bringt es da jetzt Telegram
zu sperren, es ist ja nicht so, als wäre Telegram einer von 580 Millionen Möglichkeiten,
wie man, ähm, irgendwie kommunizieren kann übers Internet, mal ganz davon abgesehen,
sorgt es sicherlich nicht dafür, wenn die Leute immer radikaler drauf sind, da müsstest
du auch Twitter und alles YouTube-Comments, du müsstest alles verbieten, ja, und außerdem
wird es garantiert nicht dafür sorgen, also wenn jetzt angeblich Telegram dafür zuständig
ist, äh, oder zu, äh, verantwortlich ist, dass die Leute quasi immer radikaler werden,
dann wird es, also angeblich, sagt man ja, ähm, dann wird es garantiert nicht dazu führen,
wenn man denen jetzt Telegram verbietet, dass die weniger radikal werden, wie soll das,
das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, also das einzige, was du machen könntest, ist mit
den Leuten reden, wobei ich glaube, bei den meisten ist da auch Hopfen und Malz verloren,
also mit denen kannst du auch nicht mal gescheit reden, aber es wird garantiert nicht dazu
führen, dass man weniger radikal wird, nur weil man jetzt Telegram verbietet, das ist
total, total hängen geblieben, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man auf die Idee kommen kann, gibt
es eigentlich eine genaue Definition, was jetzt, was jetzt eigentlich Hatespeak ist und was
nicht, weiß man ja gar nicht so genau, aber Telegram verbieten wird an dem Problem nichts
ändern, wenn du willst, dass die Leute weniger radikal werden, dann musst du nicht Telegram
verbieten, sondern du musst, äh, die Ursprünge angehen und das ist in der Regel ein langwieriger
Prozess und wird garantiert nicht dadurch irgendwie begünstigt, dass man Telegram verbietet,
ich frag mich, wie sie das überhaupt machen wollen gescheit, mal ganz davon abgesehen,
es gibt ja noch genug Möglichkeiten, übers Internet zu kommunizieren, dass es gar keiner
mitbekommt und deswegen sagen jetzt ja auch viele so nach dem Motto, Verschlüsselung
muss verboten werden, weil Verschlüsselung ist böse, da können die Leute ja reden miteinander
oder Informationen miteinander austauschen, die man nicht einsehen kann, das ist ganz
ganz böse, Verschlüsselung muss weg und am besten noch Klarnamen überall hin, das
kommt raus, wenn Leute da über Sachen entscheiden und davon überhaupt keine Ahnung haben, Telegram
ist quasi ein Instant-Messenger, ja, man könnte höchstens die Grundlagen mal anpacken,
sich zu überlegen, ok, warum haten, hassprechen die Leute denn gerade so viel und das ist
ein deutlich langwierigerer Prozess, naja, aber wer auf so bescheuerte Ideen kommt, kann
also nicht alles verbieten, plus weil mal irgendwas zu was gebraucht wurde, was nicht so gut war,
dann müsstest du alles verbieten, dann müsstest du auch Burger essen verbieten, weil es auch
nicht gut für Pepofat-Leute wie mich, weil ich ewig kein Burger mehr gefuttert habe,
jetzt wo ich gerade dabei bin, ich sollte mal wieder ein Burger essen, Massive Burger
Stells, egal, das geht mir eh auf, oh fuck, mein Handy ist runtergefallen, Moment, oh
ich hab auch noch, ich muss euch noch was sagen, ich hab letztens ein Video gesehen,
das wurde mir vorgeschlagen auf YouTube, ich habe, ich suche mittlerweile nicht mehr nach
sowas, aber das war ein Video, da ging es um, wie heißt das auf Englisch so schön, Body
Positivity oder so, so nach dem Motto, egal wie am Arsch du bist, ist alles in Ordnung,
das war so unglaublich fail, ich kanns gar nicht in Worte fassen, Leute ihr wisst, ich
bin selbst nicht der Dünste, aber dann hattest du in diesem Video welche stehen, die waren
keine Ahnung, 1,50 groß und haben irgendwie, man hat es ja nicht genau gesehen, aber keine
Ahnung, die waren 1,50 groß und 300 Kilo gewogen so nach dem Motto und dann haben die
dann erzählt so nach dem Motto, ja ich möchte mir nicht von sozialen Normen vorschreiben
lassen, wie ich auszusehen habe, das ist gesund und das ist schön und sonst was, hey, jeder,
es soll jeder mögen, was er will und ich habe überhaupt kein Problem damit, wenn die Leute
es sich schön finden, aber mal ganz im Ernst, gesund ist das garantiert nicht, ich rede
mir doch auch nicht ein, wenn ich irgendwie eine halbe Packung, was auch immer Plätzchen
gefuttert habe so nach dem Motto, ja das war jetzt aber sehr gesund, soll ich euch mal
ehrlich sagen, warum ich zu dick bin, das liegt daran, nicht weil ich sage, sieht das
geil aus oder ist das gesund oder so, ich bin zu dick, weil ich zu viel vom Rechner
sitze und zu faul bin und zu viel Fresse, das muss man halt einfach auch mal klar benennen,
es hat doch keinen Sinn sich irgendwie einzureden, das ist alles schon ok oder sonst was, ich
meine, wie sagt man so, Erkenntnis ist der erste Weg zur Besserung, ja, ich meine, ob
man jetzt aus der Erkenntnis tatenvoll ist, sei mal dahingestellt, so wie ich mich kenne
wahrscheinlich nicht, aber man kann sich doch nicht einreden, das wäre irgendwie alles
toll, also es ist doch ein Unterschied zwischen Realität akzeptieren und Realität abstreiten,
also dieses Video habe ich wirklich nicht nachvollziehen können, aber das war so ein
typisches Kekona Ami Video, da gibt es relativ viele in dieser Richtung, das verstehe ich
jetzt nicht, ganz ehrlich, also ich rede mir nicht ein, das wäre super hübsch und gesund
oder sowas, das ist doch bescheuert, ich muss sagen, es ist ja auch durchaus besser geworden
seitdem ich mich mal mindestens 1 bis 1,5 oder sogar 2 Stunden am Tag nochmal sportlich
bisschen betätige, ich sehe mich wenigstens nicht mal zu und es ist jetzt bei mir auch
nicht so als wäre das Ultra, also ich bin da nicht 1,50 und wiege 200 Kilo oder so,
aber Corona schlägt mir dazu, aber es ist schon eine ganze Ecke zu viel, ne, das habe
ich nicht verstanden und dann hat mein YouTube noch ein Video vorgeschlagen, ich weiß, wahrscheinlich
wurde mir das zweite Video vorgeschlagen, weil ich das erste Video geguckt habe, das
war ein Typ auf einer Feministendemonstration und also ich glaube, YouTube erkennt, wenn
man Videos aus einer gewissen Ecke eben guckt, dann kriegst du noch mehr davon empfohlen,
das war ein Typ auf einer Feministendemonstration mit einem Schild, genauso wie die anderen
rumgelaufen sind, dann ist er halt als einziger Mann durch diese Demonstration gelaufen und
hat halt so die üblichen Dinge erzählt, die dann da erzählt wurden und auf einmal geht
es da, es ging quasi in dieser Demonstration quasi um Gewalt gegen Frauen und Gewalt und
das ist schlecht, vollkommen richtig sehe ich auch so und auf einmal kommt eine Feministin
zu ihr Händen und haut ihm eine runter, habe ich mir auch gedacht, geiles Beispiel für
keine Gewalt, super, super Beispiel, super Exempel, geht hin und haut ihm eine runter,
oh man, also das ist wirklich voll ins eigene Bein geschossen, echter Wahnsinn, er hat gar
nichts gemacht, er ist einfach nur mitgelaufen, hat gesagt, ich supporte das, ob er da hingegangen
ist, um die wirklich zu chibäden oder nicht, kann man schlecht sagen, wahrscheinlich wollte
er sich ein bisschen chibäden, aber trotzdem kann man doch nicht so blöd sein, sich so
krass reizen und chibäden lassen, dass man seine komplett eigene Aussage untergräbt,
ok, ok, ich gebe zu, es gab ja auch um Gewalt, es ging ja in dieser Demonstration anscheinend
um Gewalt gegen Frauen, nicht um Gewalt gegen Männer, also Männer kannst du ruhig eine
bescheuern, aber wie bescheuert kann man eigentlich sein, das untergräbt quasi alles wofür man
gerade da steht und demonstriert, wenn man dem einfach eine klatscht, um quasi seinen
Standpunkt zu untermauern, war das bei den Amis, natürlich war das bei den Amis, wo
denn sonst, das ist so typisch, das muss Kaunas sein, anders geht das gar nicht, natürlich
war das bei den Amis, jetzt ging er dann noch weiter, es ging ja dann noch weiter, dann
hat er gesagt, hey was soll das hier, warum werde ich hier geschlagen und da kam dann
die Nix und hat ihm glaube ich eines von diesen Demoschildern irgendwie versucht auf den Kopf
zu hauen und sowas, ging es richtig zur Sache, ich habe auch gedacht, wie bescheuert kann
man dann sein, bei den Amis ist ganz schlimm in der Richtung, also, oh man, ich weiß gar
nicht was mit den Leuten alles los ist, ich finde das ist überhaupt kein Problem, wenn
jemand auch mal, was sagt dem ich nicht zustimme, wo ist das Problem, ich hatte letztens auch
ein Ultraschwurbler unter meinen YouTube Videos, der ging richtig ab, das habe ich euch glaube
ich gezeigt im Stream, oder, der dann angefangen hat mit, was hat er geschrieben, diese, ich
kann dieses Wort gar nicht aussprechen, diese infantilisierte Verächtlichmachung hier ist
unerträglich oder sowas hat er geschrieben, das war so typisches Schwurblerdeutsch, aber
es ist doch kein Problem, ich meine, ich habe damit überhaupt keine Schmerzen, wenn einer
was sagt, was ich anders sehe, aber, und das ist ja die Geschichte, dann sollen sich die
Leute gefälligst auch nicht wundern, wenn ich was dagegen sage, das muss ja dann auch
okay sein, aber ich habe überhaupt keine Probleme mit, wenn einer was sagt, was mir
nicht gefällt, ich finde das sogar gut, ich meine, man muss sich ja nicht permanent immer
zustimmen, aber das ist zur Zeit nicht gewollt, naja, ne, das sind keine Trolle, die sind
davon wirklich überzeugt, und das beste war, er hat da noch einen Link zu einem Schlafschafe-Video
gepostet, das ist ja nur wirklich so das größte, das größte Klischee, was es so in dieser
Richtung gibt, jeder, der das anders sieht, automatisch Schlafschafe, wer ist überhaupt
auf dieses ultra bescheuerte Wort gekommen?
Ja, gut, Twitter ist das andere Extrem, Twitter ist das andere Extrem, ich habe echt das
Gefühl, als haben sich YouTube, wer ist denn der YouTube-Chef, ist das nicht eine Chefin
sogar bei YouTube, ist das nicht die, in der Garage, in der sie Google gestartet haben,
die, das ist doch die in der Garage, wo sie Google angefangen haben, oder, die Chefin
von YouTube, also mir kommt es echt so vor, als haben sich die Chef, Chefinnen und Chefs
von, oder wie man heutzutage sagen kann, Chefinnen, also die Chefs, die Chefinnen und Chefs von
Facebook, YouTube und Google, YouTube, Twitter, Facebook und so, als haben die sich zusammengesetzt
und haben sich überlegt, okay, welche, welche Verschwörungsleute und nervige Gruppen wollt
ihr haben?
Und dann hat Twitter gesagt, ah, wir nehmen die ultrakrassen Social Justice Warrior, YouTube
hat gesagt, ah, wir nehmen alle Corona-Leugner und Facebook hat gesagt, wir nehmen den ganzen
Rest.
Auf Facebook gibt es ja einfach alles, wo du nicht möglich hältst, dass es irgendwie
existiert.
Facebook ist ja so Sammelbecken für den, für den Rest an, verrückt, ne?
Und, und die ganzen, die ganzen Boomers, ja.
Instagram und TikTok haben die ganzen Zoomer am Start, genau, die Ausdruckstanz machen
wollen, wenn sie Fakten über das US-Militär erzählen.
Kennt ihr dieses Video?
Ich kenne es auch noch, weil es letztens einer im Discord gepostet hat.
Irgendeine versucht den Leuten zu erzählen, dass das US-Militär wohl ziemlich zur Umweltverschmutzung
beiträgt und das Video geht halt irgendwie fünf Minuten und dass die, dass die TikTok-Zoomer
aufmerksam bleiben in diesem Video, macht sie quasi so Ausdruckstanz dabei, dass die,
dass die Leute nicht weggucken.
Richtig, richtig hängen geblieben.
Das ist wirklich so Sinnbild für, für aktuelle, aktuellen Content.
Ja, genau, genau, das meine ich, genau, das meine ich, Bounce-Tronic.
Oh Mann.
Und was hat Twitch bekommen?
Twitch hat den Q-Chat bekommen, das muss reichen, die ganzen, die ganzen, die restlichen, irgendwie
noch halbwegs normalen Leute sind auf Twitch, wobei man natürlich sagen muss, dass auf
Twitch auch schon viele Verrückte rumlaufen.
Auf Twitch, ja, wen hat Twitch, lass mal überlegen, wen hat Twitch bekommen?
Das S-Wort darf man nicht mal sagen, das ist ja, das ist ja verboten, davon hat Twitch
aber einige.
Was, was, was hat, was hat Twitch bekommen?
Naja, Pool-Streams, Pool-Streams und, ich glaub Twitch, ich glaub auf Twitch ist, ist
glaub ich mehr Fanboys als überall anders.
Also was da teilweise abgeht, also Personenkult und Fanboys ist glaub ich auf Twitch sogar
fast noch extremer wie woanders.
Ich weiß nicht, wen Twitch abbekommen wird, aber ich hab, ich hab den Eindruck, dass auf
Twitch tatsächlich anteilmäßig noch die gescheitesten Leute sind.
Just Chatting um 3 Uhr nachts würdest du nicht als normal bezeichnen?
Ja, es gibt überall, was ist hier los?
Ah ne, hä?
Moment, das ist genau das gleiche, was ich hier nochmal auf hab.
Just Chatting um 3 Uhr nachts ist eine Kombination aus, wir sitzen halt naggisch vor der Webcam,
ASMR-Videos, was ist denn sonst noch so nachts um 3, Just Chatting?
Also ich hab nur mitbekommen, dass letztens 3 koreanische Streamerinnen gebannt wurden
auf Twitch, weil sie sich, weil sie sich off-cam umziehen wollten und die eine war
nicht ganz off-cam genug, selbst schuld.
Ja, ansonsten keine Ahnung, was nachts um 3 Uhr auf Twitch abgeht, da bin ich selten.
Leute, ich muss noch ein bisschen mehr trinken, ich hab immer noch ziemlich, ziemlich, äh,
ich mein vielleicht auch, vielleicht klingt es ein bisschen heißer oder so, ich weiß
nicht.
Äh, mich tut immer noch der Hals weh, das war jetzt seit 3 Wochen oder so schon, aber
ich geh in der Corona-Zeit nirgendswo zum Doktor jetzt, weiß ich nicht, nächstes Jahr
wieder.
Sackt, Alter.
Na gut, also, auf welches Video, ähm, auf das wo ich reacted habe, kannst du, du kannst
im Discord gucken.
Dann doch, lieber Hetzner, das ist eine sehr gute Überleitung.
Leute, bis zum Ende des Monats, es ist nicht mehr lange Zeit, könnt ihr euch noch einen
20 Euro Startgutschein mit 20 Euro Cloudguthaben sichern mit meinem Code, wenn ihr euch jetzt
bei Hetzner anmeldet.
Bei Hetzner, in der Hetzner Cloud könnt ihr VMs mieten, bzw. Server mieten, von zu einem
günstigen Preis, angefangen bei 4 Euro im Monat, inklusive IPv4-Adresse, deswegen ist
es jetzt auch teurer geworden, das war mal 3 Euro, ähm, ich hoffe, sie kriegen es demnächst
hin, Server anzubieten, komplett ohne öffentliche IP-Adresse, dann könnte es nämlich nochmal
eine ganze Ecke billiger sein, weil die meisten Server, je nachdem, wie man das aufbaut, brauchen
überhaupt keine öffentliche IP-Adresse.
Jo, exellent.
20 Euro, guck mal, mit 20 Euro Startguthaben könnt, könnt ihr schon ein, ähm, hier,
da könnt ihr die Triplecore-Kiste fast 3 Monate betreiben.
Was gibt's da noch zu überlegen?
Soll ich jetzt registrieren und easy VM-Server sichern, was auch immer damit, dann macht
es nicht mein, ich wills gar nicht wissen, ich wills gar nicht wissen, was damit passiert.
In Norwegen, beste, exellent.
Was will man mit einem Server ohne Public IP?
Naja, du hast vielleicht Loadbalancer davor, der eine Public IP hat, und hinten dran stehen
3 Server, die brauchen keine Public IP, vor allem nicht, wenn man für die Public IP bezahlen
muss.
Für, ähm, viele Anwendungen ist das sinnvoll.
Der Preis-Champ besteht auch aus einem Frontend mit Loadbalancer und 3 Crawler-Servern, die
Crawler-Server, die bräuchten nicht unbedingt Public IP.
Könnt ihr über den Proxy rausgehen oder so?
Also ja, also das gibt's schon, äh, viele Anwendungszwecke.
So, gut, gucken wir uns mal an, was schlägt uns denn YouTube heute vor?
Was alles rot, ja, der Preis-Champ, der wird demnächst auch abgeschaltet.
Neun Dinge, um Battlefield zu einem drastisch besseren Game zu machen, tja, schauen wir uns
heute wieder Verschwörungsvideos an.
Ich weiß nicht, ich fand eins, was er letztens gebracht hat, mega witzig, weiß aber nicht,
inwieweit er Chat das witzig findet, das hier.
Das ist so, das ist so pepega Kekona, das Video, also mehr, mehr, mehr Kekona kannst
du eigentlich nicht sein, wie der Typ in diesem Video, also nicht er, sondern den, den er
zeigt.
Das wird nur noch von dem Typ getoppt, der erzählen wollte, dass Noahs Flute den Grand
Canyon in einer Woche geformt hat.
Was verdienen Fachinformatiker, ja, das gucken wir uns jetzt an, das hab ich ja auch irgendwie
offen.
Was verdienen Fachinformatiker, welches Gehalt ohne Studium, als Informatiker im öffentlichen
Dienst, ja gut, dann verdient man nix.
Was verdient ein Fachinformatiker, das gucken wir uns jetzt an, Leute, exzellent, Bäm,
welches Gehalt ohne Studium, als Informatiker im öffentlichen Dienst, aber lohnt sich das?
Das geringste Angebot war bisher 65.000 Euro jährlich, höchste waren 85.000 oder 90.000.
Das ist durchaus gut, ja, sie frage in welchem, wahrscheinlich München oder so, sie frage
in welchem Gebiet, also nicht Gebiet, Gebiet ist das falsche Wort, ich meine nicht Themengebiet,
ich meine Region, Region, meine ich, ja, also es kommt natürlich auf die Region an.
Okay, das geringste Angebot war bisher 65.000 Euro jährlich, höchste waren 85.000 oder
90.000.
Oh, das ist Tossmusik, das ist Tossmusik, das ist ACDC, das ist Tossmusik, ach nee,
der singt, ach der singt selbst, okay, das ist in Ordnung, ganz ehrlich, das ist nicht
unbedingt jetzt so, also Sänger auf ner Bühne ist jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt so das
typische Hobby eines Fachinformatikers, also die meisten dürften wahrscheinlich eher
blasse Kellerhocker wie ich sein, aber man sieht es gibt in diesem Beruf mittlerweile
alles.
Ich kann dich von Anfang an gucken, wo ist der beste Satz, wo habe ich den besten Satz
verpasst.
Das geringste Angebot war bisher 65.000 Euro jährlich, höchste waren 85.000 oder 90.000.
Ein PHP-Critical Error hat er, ja ich frag mich auch wo der herkommt, das ist immer
noch schwer zu sagen, ein Strichkummer, ich bin der Patrick, ich bin Fachinformatiker
in Systemintegration an der Technischen Hochschule in Deggendorf am Institut für Angewandte
Informatik in Freien.
Manchmal fange ich immer so um 8.30 oder um 9.00 Uhr an, Alter, könnt ihr mal aufhören
Postmusik zu spielen hier, das ist ja schrecklich, das kann ich mir denn angucken.
Das ist für mich ein bisschen die angenehmere Zeit, ich lösche das Wort einfach danach.
So, ich lösche, ah vorbei, das ist ja selbst gespielt von denen, dann ist ja okay.
Das ist mein Büro, bevor ich jetzt aber ein wenig tiefer in die Mails einsteige, glaube
ich, halte ich mir erstmal einen Kaffee, dann, ich muss einfach nur noch labern, so, sehr
gut.
Von Betriebssystem bis zum Framework kann ich eigentlich alles entscheiden, ich plan
auch die, also typische Ein-Mann-IT-Abteilung oder wie, verschiedenen Tools, die wir programmieren
und habe eben noch zwei Entwickler, mit denen ich das zusammen mache.
Probieren wir es mal mit einem Kollegen kurz, hallo Jonas, Jonas, du kannst gerne eine Kamera
einschalten.
Er ist ein bisschen schall.
Der Typ, der Typ irgendwie mag ich den, der ist cool.
Da sehe ich es, dass das Formular jetzt einfach nicht anzeigt wird, was ich jetzt mache, ist
einfach das Log aufrufen, neu starten, einfach neu starten, wenn das Formular nicht läuft.
Wenn man sich ein bisschen auskennt, kann man da einfach ein bisschen rauslesen, wo der
Fehler ist und das sehe ich jetzt ganz einfach.
Ich habe jetzt einen PHP-Critical Error.
Ich sehe nichts beim ganzen Gewackel.
Okay, PHP-Critical Error, too few arguments to function.
Aha, hat irgendjemand Mist programmiert.
Der Fehler, den wir suchen, wir haben für dieses Recapture ein sogenanntes Bundle installiert
in diesem Framework und dieses Bundle wirft einen Fehler.
Jonas, schaust du mal kurz den Fehler nach, wo es das sein könnte.
Wenn es das du jetzt nicht findest, dann schauen wir miteinander mal.
Danke dir, bis dann, sehen wir uns vor, würde ich sagen wir fahren, ein bisschen Puffer einplanen,
dann müssen wir noch kurz tanken.
Dienstreise, Turnschuh-Admin, Bester, großes Event ist heute der sogenannte Steuerungskreis
bei uns, 153, das ist so krass, was das zurzeit kostet.
Das Auto, da habe ich schon immer schon dieses Auto, war so mein Traumauto, wenn man das
mal leisten kann, ist alles gut, aber ich brauche keinen Porsche fahren, also ich habe auch
mein Traumauto, Leute, ich brauche auch kein anderes.
Meine Jahresrückblick gut ankommt, jetzt tue ich noch kurz einchecken, genau, hallo.
Okay, dann darf ich starten, quasi mit dem technischen Teil, hier hat sich die Webseite
entwickelt, acht Server.
Wie, jetzt macht ihr noch Präsentationsstelle, was ist hier los?
7000 MyTierDeck User, 10.000 Medien-Dateien haben drauf, 800.000 Datenobjekte und das
ist jetzt noch so ein Zukunftsprojekt, das ist jetzt einfach nur noch dieses Konzept.
Das ist so eine typische Präsentation für Leute, die keinen Plan haben, die kann man
nämlich mit so Zahlen immer super beeindrucken, wenn du zum Beispiel eine Webseite hast und
sagst denen, wir haben 10.000 Aufrufe, wir hatten schon 50.000 Aufrufe, dann denken
die immer, boah, 50.000 Aufrufe, Alter, ist das geil.
So, dabei ist das je nachdem gar nicht besonders viel und 800.000 Datenobjekte, was, ja, also
das ist so eine typische Präsentation für Leute, die keine Ahnung haben, aber das muss
man halt manchmal machen.
Auf vier Seiten eine PDF, sondern es ist jetzt einfach dieses moderne Webkonzept, das Konzept,
das wir nächstes Jahr einreihen könnten, das wollte ich in den Steuerungskreis jetzt
einfach mal.
Das ist der Steuerungskreis.
Ich finde das geil, der Steuerungskreis hat mal wieder keinen Plan von dem, was eigentlich
abgeht, aber das ist ja normal.
Agil, danke für die, ach, nicht Agil, Agi, ich habe Agil gelesen aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Agi, 25, danke für den Prime Sub.
Perfekt, das nehme ich mit, das war's von meiner Seite, dann bis zum nächsten Mal.
Oh, dieses Tisch gekloppt, triggert das noch irgendjemand, dieses Tisch gekloppt?
Das ist so dieses Nachhinein, Alter, bin ich froh, dass es endlich vorbei ist, ich habe
keinen Bock mehr auf den Scheiß hier, ja, ich habe keine Ahnung, um was es ging, aber
ja, ja, Anerkennung, Tisch gekloppt, das ist, ich weiß nicht, ich finde das immer richtig
stumm.
Ups, hallo?
YouTube, was jetzt?
Ah, meine Maus ist der Meinung.
Das geringste Angebot war bisher 65.000 Euro jährlich, höchste waren 65.000 Euro jährlich,
höchste waren 85.000 oder 90.000, ich habe jetzt einen PHP-Critical-Error, habe gerade
keine Idee, wo der herkommt, am Schluss ist der Fehler dann ein Strich, kann man so an
der Pfanne steuern.
Das kann durchaus sein.
Hallo, ich bin der Patrick, ich bin der Facht.
Hä, Moment, was zum...
Hä, warum hast du das jetzt noch mal von vorne gestartet?
Das war's von meiner Seite, du kannst natürlich jetzt nicht erwarten, dass du da wie beim
Auftritt von uns dann nach jedem Ding und Applaus gehst, um das geht es auch gar nicht,
sondern ich schaue in die Gesichter, die sagen, hä, cool, ich habe mir jetzt quasi so ein
bisschen die Vorabbestätigung eingeholt, meine Ideen weiter zu verfolgen.
Servus, das ist der Ulrich.
Ganz ehrlich, die, was auch immer das dafür ein Entscheidungs-Lenkungsausschuss, wie auch
immer das mal so ein Zeichen ist, die sind wahrscheinlich froh, wenn irgendjemand was
vorstellt und was sagt, dass sie sich selbst keine Gedanken machen müssen, sondern einfach
nur was abnicken müssen.
Meine Tastatur hat einen PHP-Critical-Error, das wird es sein.
Das ist mein kleiner Bruder.
Ja so, genau so stelle ich mir das in Bayern vor, da wird erst mal abends eine Runde Bier
getrunken.
Ich kriege über Xing oder LinkedIn, das kriegt man jetzt zur Zeit als Informatiker natürlich,
das ist ein und andere Angebot und ich schreibe mir aus, ich habe das und das gelesen, passet
vor, die Tätigkeiten zu beinstehen.
Ach, das ist 12 Uhr mittags, ja gut, das ist ja noch bayerischer.
Als Abend, das ist ja noch bayerisch, zum Mittag erst mal schöne Bier.
Wir bräuchten eigentlich, guck mal, wir haben ein französisches Emote, wir haben ein Ami-Emote,
wir haben ein russisches Emote, eigentlich bräuchten wir noch irgendein bayerisches
Emote.
Was ist denn so ein typisches Bayern-Emote?
Keke Bavaria, keine Ahnung, was es da gibt.
Breze.
Das ist der Benchmark, das höchste waren glaube ich 85.000 oder 90.000.
Was ist der Bench...
Was ist der Benchmark?
Seck.
Das ist der Benchmark.
Was?
Und ich schreibe mir aus, ich habe das und das gelesen, passet vor, die Tätigkeiten
zu beinstehen.
Das ist der Benchmark, das höchste waren glaube ich 85.000 oder 90.000.
Ehrlich.
Das ist viel Geld.
Die vom öffentlichen Rundfunk lacht sich da drüber kaputt, was 85.000 ist viel Geld,
null ich krieg viel mehr und ich muss da für nichts machen, wir könnten jede Blotte
das Geld aus der Tasche ziehen, überhaupt kein Problem, ich werde bezahlt, egal was
ich mache und egal was passiert.
Montana Black schaut sich mit seinen 80.000 Livestream Viewer, der lohnt sich da so, wo
es Arzt verdient und ob das genug ist, diskutiert da mit seinen Followern, das ist schon heftig.
Das ist ja eine geile Idee, das hat ja noch nie irgendjemand gemacht oder?
Was hat noch nie jemand gemacht?
Hä?
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Komm mal einen Kronen zurück, zwölf stimmt so, tschau, was hat noch nie jemand gemacht?
Okay, ja das ist der liebste Gebrauch, ich mein er arbeitet wenigstens was im Vergleich
zu den anderen diese gezeigt haben, ja erstmal ordentliche Loginscreen, so muss das ganze
natürlich sein.
Der begrüßt mich immer, wenn ich auf dem Server bin und bei Rot ist die Signalfarbe,
da muss man ein bisschen aufschauen, weil wir bewegen uns da im produktiven Bereich natürlich.
Das ist sinnvoll?
Wir werden jetzt mal schauen, was das Bundle, das wir da installiert haben und das ist einfach
sinnvoll.
Das ist tatsächlich sinnvoll, finde ich auch sinnig, wenn man produktive Kisten, andere
Loginpromts und andere Farben verpasst.
Ja, also so blöd das klingt, weil in der perfekten Welt weiß natürlich immer jeder
auf was er sich einloggt, aber wir wissen alle, dass das in der Praxis nicht so ist.
Wie man für eine genaue Version hat, möglicherweise ist die Version einfach nicht gleich.
Man muss einfach, ich sag jetzt mal, ein Freak sein in dem, was man macht.
Man muss halt planen.
Man muss halt planen, einfach versuchen die Materie zu verstehen und das kann man nicht
im Studium lernen und auch nicht in der Ausbildung, das muss man einfach.
Man kann in einem Studium theoretische Grundlagen lernen und auch viele Hintergründe lernen.
Ja, ich sag mal Binary Tree in Wörtern, aber gerade, wenn irgendwie einer anruft oder
du ein Ticket bekommst und drin steht, ich anwende xy wie ein Fehler, das ist nichts,
das was du in der Ausbildung lernst, das ist auch nichts, was du in einem Studium lernst,
das lernst du nur einfach mit ein bisschen Erfahrung und du lernst auch die erste Sache,
die du lernst, dass der Typ, was der in das Ticket schreibt oder was der am Telefon erzählt
hat, in der Regel nicht das sein muss, was wirklich das Problem ist.
Ja, die Leute erzählen viel Zeug, wenn der Tag lang ist, erfinden im Zweifelsfall was
dazu, dichten sich was dazu, weil sie denken, es wäre so, es hätte was damit zu tun, also
am besten ist, wie er es gemacht hat, das stimmt schon, einfach mal selbst ins Log
gucken, was ist denn passiert, als er sich versucht hat einzuloggen, was ist denn kaputt
gegangen, weil du kannst in der Regel auf Userreports schon mal gar nicht, aber auch
auf von irgendwelchen Entwicklern, egal von irgendwem, kannst du dich nicht wirklich drauf
verlassen.
Ah, yes, obvios, was sehen wir hier, Zach, ich muss mal kurz gucken, also, wenigstens
ist das, was verwendet der denn da, ich sehe jetzt die Leiste unten nicht, also ich würde
fast sagen, das ist irgendein Linux mit Tiling Window Manager oder sowas, ich erkenne es
jetzt an der Stelle nicht wirklich, aber wie Mac sieht es auch, das ist ein Mac, das sieht
überhaupt nicht aus wie ein Mac, der hat da oben gar nicht so seine Standarddinger, ah,
das ist iTerm im Fullscreen oder was, T-Max Fullscreen iTerm, nee, das ist die eingebaute
Splitting Funktion von iTerm, ja, stimmt, man sieht das, man sieht das auch an der Schriftart,
die Schriftart ist auch die alte default Mac Schriftart, das ist nicht die neue default
Mac Schriftart.
So, ok, war www, typischer Ort für irgend so ein PAP, Composer, ok, das ist schon ein
bisschen was neueres, das ist nicht so ganz oldschool PAP, shit, schon irgendwas halbwegs,
die Excel Web Zone Capture R, ok, wie viele Hydranten sind im Bild, markieren sie die
Ladengeschäfte von vorne, wie viele Brücken sehen sie und wie viele Fahrräder stehen
im Fahrradständer, also Capture, dann irgendwelche Bande, ich hab von einem PAP nicht wirklich
viel Ahnung, Symphony, Symphony ist glaube ich mit Laravel zusammen so eines der beliebtsten
PAP-Dinger oder, so Web Framework technisch, ich hab keine Ahnung großartig davon, das
müsst ihr mir jetzt sagen, falls ihr damit was macht, ok, PHP Unit, wie wollen die wirklich
sagen, die haben Tests, das glaube ich erst wenn ich sehe, das Package ist wahrscheinlich
einfach nur drinnen und wird nicht benutzt, also die haben bestimmt keine Tests, Tests
alter, Pepo, hey, ja das ist ziemlich bayerisch, das finde ich, Moment, ich edde das mal kurz,
ich brauch mal kurz mein Bayern Emote, Zach, muss ich mal kurz edden, wenn wir gerade dabei
sind, ja Symphony ist sogar ziemlich weit mit Database, Database My Creation, wobei
Database My Creation gab es ja schon in Ruby on Rails, Bayern, das ist, das ist, das ist
ganz gutes Bayern Emote, oder, ich findet ihr das, ich finde das eigentlich ganz gut
passend, das ist die selbe Version, tatsächlich ein bisschen eine Sackgasse, vielleicht finden
wir einen Fehler heute auch nicht, da müssen wir einfach machen weiter, das ist in der
IT kann das auch mal ewig lang dauern, drei ein Error, genau, am Schluss ist der Fehler
dann ein Strichgehammer oder so an der falschen Stelle, aber das ist einfach Teil des Berufs,
das kann schon sein, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, noch mal so, wisst ihr was jetzt gut wäre,
ich sag's ja nochmal, ich sag's ja nochmal, wisst ihr was jetzt gut wäre, wenn der Quellcode
in einer Versionsverwaltung liegen würde und man irgendeine Möglichkeit hat eine Testkiste
damit zu starten, sei es nur, dass es eine Docker Container ist oder eben wirklich eine
Test vor allem, die dafür gebaut ist und man versucht diesen Fehler einfach mal nachzustellen
mit der aktuellen Version, gucken ob der da ist in der Testumgebung und danach mal schauen,
gehen wir mal eine Versionstack zurück oder gehen wir mal ein paar Comets zurück, es
gibt ja auch Git bisect, ich weiß nicht ob ihr das schon mal verwendet habt, jemand von
euch verwendet hat, da kannst du in Git relativ gut so, wie nennt man das, quasi Comet splitten,
so nach dem Motto da ging's noch, da ging's nicht und dann wieder dazwischen und dann
findest du relativ schnell das Comet was es kaputt gemacht hat, genau, binary search,
das wär natürlich jetzt sehr praktisch, aber gucken wir mal weiter, soll ich euch mal was
sagen, das ist auch das, was ich wirklich gerne mache, wenn irgendwas kaputt ist, einfach
5 Stunden zu gucken woran es jetzt liegt und das wieder zu fixen, das mach ich gerne,
es mag jetzt vielleicht Leute gehen und sagen, das ist doch dumm, was macht daran Spaß,
das mach ich gerne und dann am Ende natürlich noch 2 Stunden drüber erzählen, was man jetzt
geiles raus bekommen hat, aber das mach ich gerne, das mach ich viel viel lieber als irgendwelche
komischen Excel Listen durchgucken oder irgendwelche, was weiß ich, Daily Meetings, Wartungsarbeiten,
Runden oder irgendwelche bescheuerten Diskussionen, so nach dem Motto, welche Services können
wir hier hin umziehen, was machen wir da, ich mach am liebsten sowas.
Vielleicht, dann hat man doch irgendeinen Einfall, ja jetzt geht's, dann ist das Problem
gelöst, das ist schon ein tolles Gefühl, ja, der Typ ist wenigstens Real Einfach Informatiker,
sitzt vor dem Rechner, probiert 3 Stunden aus und sagt dann LOL, was ist das, genau so,
so muss das sein.
Es war tatsächlich ein Part des Bundles, den wir nicht brauchen, der halt einfach mit
dabei ist, Abhängigkeiten wurden aktualisiert und haben es kaputt gemacht, ja Dependency
Management ist halt auch so ein schönes Ding, der hat einfach den Fehler ausgelöst
und den Part, den wir brauchen, der funktioniert eh, ja, das ist völlig normal in der Webprogrammierung,
dass man einfach mal ein Fehler sucht, wie hat er das überhaupt hinbekommen, wie hat
er das jetzt hinbekommen, er hat weder ein Ticket bearbeitet dafür, noch hat er irgendwie
einen Daily Scrum dazwischen gemacht, noch hatte er ein Kanban Board, noch war er sonderlich
agil, das ist doch überhaupt nicht möglich das Problem zu fixen, das geht doch gar nicht,
das ist doch laut Save Web 5.0 Agile Zertifikat 528 gar nicht möglich, dass man da überhaupt
jetzt Probleme löst, das geht überhaupt nicht, wo ist die User Story Leute, wo ist die User
Story dafür, ich als User möchte beim Einloggen ein fehlerfreies Formular bekommen, du musst
erstmal die User Story definieren, dass du überhaupt was machen kannst, das kann überhaupt
nicht funktionieren, der hätte mindestens 2 Tage Vorbereitung gebraucht, dass er überhaupt
anfangen könnte, er hat noch nicht mal eine Sprintplanung gemacht und das Daily Scrum
und Stand Up hat auch gefehlt und natürlich die passende Retrospektive um den Prozess
Workflow zu verbessern, also natürlich meine ich das nicht ernst, es gibt ja Leute die
sind immer weiter gesagt, ich meine das so, natürlich meine ich das nicht ernst, ich
finde es bescheuert, dass mittlerweile so viel drum herum gedichtet wird an teilweise
simpelste, ich will nicht sagen, dass das simpel ist was er gemacht hat, aber ihr wisst
wie ich es meine, dass um einfachste Sachen so viel drum herum gedichtet wird mittlerweile.
Umso mehr gefreut man sich dann wenn man es findet, ja das stimmt dann freut man sich
danach, denen tue ich monatlich 4070 Euro brutto, das entspricht in meiner Lohnsteuerklasse
1 2500 Euro grob netto, wie der kriegt weniger als ich bei 4 Tagen, was ist denn das, ich
habe gedacht der kriegt 85000 oder so hat er doch am Anfang erzählt, dem müssen die
mehr Geld bezahlen, das ist ja nichts, ach ne der hat am Anfang erzählt das waren Angebote
die er bekommen hat, aber krass ey, das ist nicht viel, also ich will jetzt nicht sagen
das ist nichts, weil das ist nichts ist natürlich im Vergleich zu Leuten die vielleicht in
den Branchen arbeiten, da ist das ganz schön viel immer noch, aber dem sollten sie durchaus
mehr bezahlen, weil er macht ja auch einen kompetenten Eindruck, ne 40 Stunden Woche,
ich weiß sehr wohl von Freunden und Bekannten, dass in der freien Wirtschaft das auch manchmal
überspannt wird, wenn da Kundenprojekte eben da sind, ja das stimmt da hat er recht, das
ist bei manchen so, gerade wenn du im Consultingbereich arbeitest ist das so, aber bei mir ist das
zum Beispiel nicht so, ich meine ich mache zwar manchmal ein paar Sachen auch so, außer
der Reihe nach, aber im Großen und Ganzen ist eigentlich das vorbei, 4 Tage, 8 Stunden,
ne die sind gar nicht 8, 7, 7 Stunden, 8,50 oder so, dann ist das vorbei, was er verdient
ich glaube 54.000, ne 52.000 Euro oder so, ja da ist durchaus noch was nach oben.
Und die müssen dann am Wochenende fertig werden, aber am Wochenende spiele ich gern
Musik und Auftritte und das würde mich dann eher nicht so glücklich machen.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich eher gedacht das Spiel Halo ranked am Wochenende.
Da können wir quasi für einen kleinen Betrag proben, monatlich, haben wir quasi im oberen
Stock, das ist quasi unser Proberaum, da ist Schlagzeug aufgebaut, Anlage nebenan.
Jetzt kommt erstmal Death Metal in die Runde, aber ne wir wissen ja sie machen ja ACDC Coverband
oder sowas.
Und das ist unser Studio und ich würde ein bisschen sagen so unser Chillplatz, also
so ein Schlagplatz.
Natürlich, wie es sich für die Bayern gehört, erst einmal ein Bier dabei, na klar.
Dann haben wir ein Rockband, was wir heute machen ist eben einen neuen Song ausarbeiten,
ich tue meistens so Basic Akkorde schreiben und ein bisschen einen Text dazu und überlege
man so eine Gesangsmelodie, das wäre doch cool und dann zeige ich dir so einen Jojo,
der richtig Gitarre spielen kann, der macht dann Akkorde, die wieder keiner versteht außer
er.
Und dann ist schon ein Ziel, dass jeder richtig Spau hat, wenn er spielen muss, nein, klar
der Scherz.
Spau hat, Spau hat, das heißt Spaß hat oder Spau hat, alles klar.
Ich muss sagen, ohne Scheiß, in diesem Video sind mir die Leute durchaus fast alle sympathisch.
Das ist das erste Video dieser Reihe, was wir gucken, wo das so ist.
Bei den letzten hätte ich alles gesagt, irgendwie sind es komische Leute, aber mit denen kann
ich mich irgendwie identifizieren.
Dann macht man es meistens so, dass man das Geld, das wir einnehmen, durch 6 teilen,
wir haben fünf Personen, also jeder kriegt quasi seinen Anteil und die sechste Person
ist die Bandkasse.
Der erste Auftritt vor Live-Publikum war unfassbar schwierig, ich war unfassbar glücklich danach,
aber es war sehr schwierig.
So dieser, ich verlasse jetzt meine Komfortzone-Moment hat immer bisher in meinem Leben zu
was Megapositiven geführt, auch wenn es sehr, sehr schwierig ist, die Komfortzone zu verlassen,
das ist natürlich klar, und wird es ein Hit, das könnte ein Hit werden, okay, ich glaube
wir haben es für heute, ich habe das aufgenommen, das Gute ist, dass ich nicht weit weg gewohnt.
Ach ja, also wenn der Kelmi noch nicht sympathisch genug war, dann jetzt.
Das ist der Baggierer schon, das ist der Baggierer, hallo, ja, hallo erstmal, da ist so mein Bad
Cave.
Wo ist die RGB, wo sind die RGBs, guck mal sogar noch, ja, aja ja stellt es an der Wand,
also allein das Mikro, glaube ich, kostet 360 Euro, Interface dazu, ja muss sein, Stimmnummer
150, dann der Kopfhörerverstärker 150, pro Box, glaube ich, 300 Euro, Fender Telecaster,
die hat glaube ich 1700 Euro gekostet, also das Musikzeug ist eigentlich das teuerste,
ist das O-Saft?
Ja, frisch gepresst.
Frisch gepresst, wer macht sich denn die Arbeit?
Stell uns gleich mal gut, also heute steht für den Nebenjob nicht so viel auf dem Plan,
da ist ein Plugin abzudaten, grundsätzlich bin ich jetzt für Homepage Programmierung
da angestellt, aber bei allem drum herum in der IT oder beim Troubleshooting, zum Beispiel
vor allem wenn der Homepage kaputt ist, bin ich meistens in der Agentur der Einzige, der
die reparieren kann, ich kann genau die zwei Sachen.
Ok, wahrscheinlich haben sie sonst in der Agentur noch irgendwelche Supermarketing Stunks,
Leute.
Musik und IT und deswegen mache ich jetzt Musik und IT, ich habe eigentlich schon meistens
wirklich Bock, richtig in die Arbeit zu gehen, vielleicht ist das nicht am Montag so, aber
am Dienstag schon.
Ja, verstehe ich, das liegt aber auch daran, dass er sich um die Sachen kümmern kann, auf
die er Bock hat.
Wenn der jetzt seinen Tag aus der Hälfte Daily Scrums, komischen Meetings, Runden,
Printplanungen, Daily und Ticketgeschäfts bestehen würde, hätte er auch keinen Bock.
Nice, ja das war ein gutes Video, cool, dass ihr zugeschaut habt, es sollte mal zumindest
ein bisschen Werbung machen für den YouTube-Channel der Band oder irgendwie sowas jetzt, da gibt
es noch was von einem Bullock, cool, dass ihr zugeschaut habt, hier gibt es noch ein Video
von einem IT-Konsultant und hier gibt es noch ein Video von einem IT-Beamten und ja, mit
dem Unterschied, mit dem Unterschied, dass er der Einzige ist, der irgendwas gearbeitet
hat.
Und vergesst das abonnieren nicht, bis bald.
Ich weiß doch, der Projektleiter hat irgendwelche komischen Programmierübungen gemacht den
ganzen Tag und der Consultant war abends im Wald und hat Bäume gefällt, da kann ich
mich noch dran erinnern.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an?
Zeit mal her, was haben wir hier schönes zu bieten?
Wir können uns von Levelcap gibäten lassen, aber da habe ich eigentlich keinen Bock drauf.
Ultimate Tierless Battlefield Technik 27 Minuten, Alter, ist ja klar.
Warum wir nicht nach Aliens suchen sollen.
Exposed, das habe ich noch vor letztem Jahr, vor letzter Woche, offen.
Tribula und danke für den Sub, Poggers.
Okay, wir lassen uns jetzt von Levelcap mal kurz gibäten.
Levelcap hier.
Und diese Woche im Spiel, Battlefield 2042 hat neue Rewards und Modes.
Ja, Battlefield 2042 hat vor allem komischen Penguin-Weihnachts-Anhänger, den sie auf
Twitter promotet haben und die Leute, das muss ich euch mal zeigen, das ist so witzig.
Weil es so die Diskrepanz zwischen Realität und Marketing-Stonks zeigt.
Was, Denai, danke für den Sub, guck mal, die posten sowas hier, haven't sent you a
Holiday-Karte yet?
We have the perfect one, Battlefield.
Und was meint ihr, wie die Antworten darauf sind?
Was meint ihr, wie die Antworten darauf sind?
Sagen die Leute, oh cool, eine Holiday-Karte, ja, das haben wir schon immer drauf gewartet.
Oder sagen die Leute, DICE fix your fucking game.
Ok, das kam jetzt erst dabei, gestern als ich da reingeguckt habe, waren die Comments
zum größten Teil alle negativ.
Fix your game, genau, davon habe ich total viel gesehen.
Fix aim assist, I'm unhappy when I play this, better optimization, genau, FPS, crashed fixen,
Tomboy, danke für den Sub, ok, schauen wir mal kurz weiter, stehen geblieben, ich wusste
gar nicht, dass Stalker 2 NFTs machen will, Blizzard 0W, ja, und die Leute hängen sich
auf, die Leute regen sich auf, wir haben das doch vor einem Monat zum Vollpreis gekauft
und jetzt ist es billiger, aber das war eigentlich davon auszugehen, oder?
Deswegen noch mal extra dumm, wenn man sich zum Vollpreis gekauft hat, ich habe es mir
auch zum Vollpreis gekauft, wobei ne, das stimmt nicht, ich hatte einen Code, aber das
war ein Code für den Vollpreis, also, nein, für die Gold Edition, so rum, Free Weekend,
Residenz Leaper, Ppega 29 Challenge, was besseres hätten sie sich jetzt überhaupt überlegen
können, ja, wirklich kein Menschspiel,
das
er löst.
Das ist ja schön, wenn die Issues getrackt werden von DICE, die haben ja sogar sich dazu
hinreißt zu sagen, so nach dem Motto, jeder Reddit-Post wird getrackt oder irgendwie sowas
haben sie mal erzählt.
Ganz ehrlich, mit der Geschwindigkeit, die sie da an Tag legen, ist das Game in 5 Jahren
vielleicht mal spielbar.
Ganz ehrlich, das was bis jetzt gefixt wurde, das ist ja Dinger, die nie hätten auch nur
ansatzweise in einem Relistenspiel sein sollen, aber es hat nichts bisher an den grundlegenden
Problemen, die das Spiel hat geändert, dass es eben sackt, dass es ein liebloses dahingeklatschtes
Stück Battlefield ist, hat keines der Updates bisher was dran geändert.
Ja, iDarkSide, das ist so, ich habe hier Urlaub seit einem Monat, seit genau einem Monat habe
ich Urlaub, ja aber ich habe auch E-Mails bekommen und eine E-Mail war ganz merkwürdig,
es war ein blauer Hintergrund mit Schnee drauf und weißer Schrift drauf, irgendjemand hat
sich gedacht, das lässt sich gut lesen, äh, falsches Video.
Okay und was genau hat es jetzt mit NFTs zu tun?
Ich meine, das ist doch was, was man stinknormale Kickstarter Belohnungen machen könnte, was
hat es denn überhaupt damit zu tun, außer dass es irgendwie den aktuellen Trend mitspielt?
Also ich meine, wenn irgendjemand sich quasi das Kickstarter Tier ersteigert hat, werde
ein NPC in dem Spiel, fahr zum Entwickler hin, lass dich 3D modeln und lass dich in
das Spiel packen, okay, aber was genau hat es mit NFTs zu tun?
Äh, ja Hecci, das gibt's, du kannst mal im Archiv gucken, im Archiv ist das bestimmt
Render.
Wir sind übrigens gerade dabei, was heißt wir, die Big Brain Mods aus meinem Discord
und hier auf Twitch sind gerade dabei, alle VODs auf YouTube hochzuladen, auf einem extra
Channel, mit dem ich nichts zu tun habe, was auch ganz gut ist, weil falls es Daught Strikes
gibt, ist mein Account nicht betroffen.
Man könnte, man könnte auch einfach Kickstarter Tiers machen.
Oder so, wie Star Citizen das schon seit Jahren macht und irgendwie immer noch damit
durchkommt, den Scheiß auf der Homepage verkaufen.
Warum auch immer das NFTs sein müssen?
Was ist denn der Vorteil davon, dass das irgendwie ein Hashtagwert in einer Krypto-Blockchain
oder nee, ich kann immer noch nicht genau beschreiben, was ein NFT eigentlich ist.
Gibt es irgendjemand, der wirklich griffig und kurz beschreiben kann, was ein NFT ist?
Das würde ich mal chat, seid mal Big Brain.
Das stimmt ja gar nicht, das stimmt ja auch gar nicht.
Moment, das wird immer gesagt, aber das stimmt doch gar nicht.
Es ist ein digitaler Gegenstand, der auch einfach nur dir gehört.
Ja, deswegen kannst du dir den Kram von Google Drive runterladen und es gibt sogar Torrents
mit den mit 50 Terabyte NFT Bildern.
Der gehört nicht nur dir.
Den kann sich jeder runterladen mittlerweile, zum größten Teil.
NFT ist, wenn du die Dinge ersteigerst, kriegst du irgendwo einen Google Drive Download Link
oder sowas.
Es ist schwer in Wort zu fassen und uns zu umreißen.
Wie ein CS-Semester mit einzigartiger Float und Besitzer-Historie, für Game-Item trifft
es das wahrscheinlich ganz gut.
Was ist denn ByteStrikes, zeige ich her.
NFC sind einzigartige Besitz-Zertifikate in der Blockchain, nur Besitz-Zertifiker, ja
super.
Das bringt es halt voll.
Wenn sich jeder runterladen kann.
Genau, das Beispiel habe ich ja auch letztens gebracht.
Das ist wie wenn in einem Museum daneben ein Bild eine Namensplakette hängen würde, aber
das bedeutet nicht automatisch, dass das Bild dir in irgendeiner Art und Weise gehören
würde.
Die gehört noch nicht mal die Namensplakette.
Es ist sehr merkwürdig.
Na zumindest, es gibt ja komplette Games und neue Scams, jemand mal was von Earth 2 gehört?
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Scamas hoch 10, wo sich jetzt herausgestellt hat, bei denen ist noch nicht mal irgendetwas
mit NFTs, sondern es ist im Prinzip einfach eine schnicknormale Datenbank im Hintergrund,
aber sie tun so als wäre es krass Krypto und sonst was.
Ach ja, bei Earth 2 konnte man übrigens auch das Profil der Leute mit einem Script Tag
in der Profilbeschreibung kaputt machen.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen dachte man sich, es ist eine gute Idee Script Tags nicht zu
es capen.
Kein Witz, kein, kein Witz, egal, gucken wir weiter.
Ja Phil Spencer, ganz ehrlich, Phil Spencer erzählt das, was der Xbox Marketing Strategie
gerade am besten in den Kram passt, weil ganz davon abgesehen, ich gebe Ihnen in diesem
Punkt recht, aber wir dürfen nicht davon ausgehen, dass wenn der jetzt sagt, dass das
quasi schlimmes Ausnutzungszeug ist, NFTs in Spielen, dass die nicht nächsten Monat
ein eigenes NFT Game ankündigen.
Also das Kurzzeitgedächtnis solcher Marketing Strongs Leute ist relativ kurzfristig.
Also die sagen heute, NFTs sind der Teufel und morgen kündigen sie ein eigenes NFT Spiel
an.
Immer nur weil das Phil Spencer heute sagt, hat es keinerlei Relevanz für die Zukunft.
Es ist ja nicht mal Content, NFTs sind ja kein Content im eigentlichen Sinne, NFTs in
einem Spiel ist vielleicht höchstens eine History, wo du gucken kannst, wem das Item
mal gehört hat, der Content hat ja damit gar nichts zu tun, der Content ist ein normales
3D Model im Game, was es geben muss, unabhängig von NFTs.
Es ist ja nicht so, als wären beispielsweise das 3D Model irgendwie in der Blockchain gespeichert
oder so.
Wisst ihr was das witzige ist bei Activision Blizzard aktuell?
Da gibt es fast täglich neuen Shit, der rauskommt und mittlerweile ist der Scheißhaufen schon
so groß, dass wenn da jetzt einfach nur noch eine weitere Wurst oben drauf kommt, interessiert
es schon gar keinem mehr.
Was macht eigentlich, wo wir gerade dabei sind, der Kurs so?
Ah, Bobby war mal kurz vorm Rausschmiss hier, würde ich sagen.
Hier hat er kurz gezittert, als gings wieder ein Stückchen rauf.
Wer braucht denn für Warzone schon bitteschön Qualitäts- und Spieletester?
Told by Activision Blizzard, known for working on Call of Duty Warzone.
Those 12 developers represent one third of the studio's QA team.
Activision Blizzard is converting 500 contract workers to full-time employees this year.
The layoffs at Raven are 12 of 20 contractors getting the boot across all of Activision
Blizzard's studios.
These layoffs have caused company-wide walkout protests.
A company-wide email was sent by Chief Administrative Officer Brian Belletow, that asked employees
to take time to consider the consequences of your signature on unionization documents.
And of course the reaction to this email was predictable.
Take time to consider your, okay, das heißt, man soll sich genau überlegen, ob man quasi,
das ist kein Betriebsrat, das ist eine Gewerkschaft, also man soll sich genau überlegen, was
für Konsequenzen haben könnte, wenn man das unterschreibt, dass man für den Beitritt
oder die Gründung einer Gewerkschaft ist.
Man könnte das jetzt ähnlich, man könnte das quasi in Deutschland ähnlich übersetzen
zu irgendwas mit Betriebsrat im Endeffekt.
Es ist natürlich was anderes, aber man hat es hier beispielsweise von Amazon auch schon
öfters gehört, dass die nicht gerade happy sind, wenn die Leute das Thema Betriebsrat
ansprechen.
Aktivision Blizzard will keine Art von Unionformen verhindern, und dieses E-Mail ist eine Schreie
Taktik.
Die Mitarbeiter haben es nicht, und haben sogar eine GoFundMe-Page gestartet, die über
300.000 Leute geholfen hat, die von den Walkouts eingeführt wurden, um mögliche Zukunftswalkouts
zu finanzieren.
Aktivision Blizzard hat auch vorhin eine Diversity Report eröffnet.
Das zeigt, dass Diversity Hires viele neue Mitarbeiter eröffnet haben.
Es hat, glaube ich, ich glaube, das ist immer was, ok, also, Moment, Corona, also, man darf
doch nicht davon ausgehen, dass die bei Blizzard jetzt die Leute einstellen, weil sie davon
irgendwie überzeugt sind.
Die stellen die Leute ein, ich meine, was soll da ein Diversity Hire sein, so nach dem Motto,
wir sind in Statistiken, haben wir zu wenig Schwarze, haben wir zu wenig Frauen, haben
wir zu wenig Asiaten, haben wir zu wenig, ja wobei Asiaten wahrscheinlich, haben wir
zu wenig Latinos, Latinas, was auch immer, so, was macht man jetzt, ok, man hiert jetzt
einfach welche, dass es in den Statistiken besser aussieht.
Ja, geil, das führt natürlich sicherlich dazu, dass die zugrunde legende Kultur in
diesem Unternehmen besser wird, ganz bestimmt, ganz bestimmt.
Das ist einfach nur, ah, seht mal her, wir können in unserem Report schreiben, wir haben
jetzt richtig krass Diversity, aber Menschenrechte gehen uns immer noch am Arsch vorbei, das
ist ja egal, aber wir haben jetzt Diversity geheiert.
Das ist einfach nur, dass man wieder besser dasteht, unterm Strich.
Es geht nicht darum, dass man irgendwie wirklich was ändern will da dran, für die läuft es
doch viel zu gut, die verdienen Milliarden, warum sollen die da was dran ändern wollen,
das ist alles nur um den heißen Breit rumherum gemanagt.
In their last fiscal year, but very few of them are for executive positions, the implication
is that diversity hires are being looked over for leadership roles when the company is promising
to become more diverse and inclusive.
Inclusive ist nichts, was du mit diversity hires irgendwie fördern könntest.
Inclusiveness muss von den Leuten, das muss von der Kultur ausgehen, dass du quasi Leute,
wie soll ich sagen, wertschätzt, egal wer sie sind, wo sie herkommen, das ist, das ist
eine innere Eigenschaft einer Unternehmenskultur, das ist nichts, was du mit, wir hiren jetzt
einfach viele aus Südamerika, viele Schwarze und viele Asiaten irgendwie ändern könntest.
Weil da wird sich einer prinzipiellen Kultur in dieser Firma nichts ändern, außer dass
dann eben halt mehr Schwarze Asiaten und Südamerikaner schlecht behandelt werden.
Die werden ja nicht jetzt auf einmal über Nacht zu besseren Menschen dort im Management,
die z.B.
performance issues it was so bad that sony actually pulled it from the playstation store
and issued around 30 000 refunds the 1.8 million dollar settlement is barely a scratch compared
to the whopping 563 million the game made in sales throughout 2020 and according to a vgc
report cyberpunk seems to be going on its second wind now that many of the game's bugs
have been fixed and future expansions are being worked on after making fans wait an
entire decade for a new splinter cell game ubisoft have announced a remake ja ja das
neue splinter cell soll doch auch nfts haben die original 2002 remake ubisoft promises
that splinter cell is a core part of the studios identity and to expect a high quality modernization
of the right i sag euch wisst ihr was splinter cell gebraucht hat open world und türme ohne
aufwald und türme geht da gar nichts heidel the game will be completely rebuilt from the ground
up using ubisoft snowdrop engine which was recently used for the division 2 the game will
feature dynamic lighting and shadows that are incorporated in the game's design the main changes
will be in animations and movement throughout the world making sure that there's a mixture of old
gameplay with the innovation seen in more recent titles ubisoft has not released any gameplay
footage and there's no eta for a launch minecraft is now the first game to net one trillion views on
youtube minecraft is undoubtedly the most popular game in the world it sold 148 million copies since
launched in 2009 and currently has 140 sogar ich guck ab und zu minecraft videos obwohl ich
minecraft nicht spiele active users per month and to celebrate youtube dedicated a website to the
creators ich habe ja microsoft damals für bescheuert gehalten als sie das gekauft haben ja also nicht
wirklich für bescheuert aber ich habe mir gedacht alter der minecraft hype ob das noch so lang
anhält aber da haben die wirklich richtig gutes händchen gehabt in videos that have helped the
game reach such a wild figure to put it into minecraft ist das world of warcraft der heutigen
jugend quasi nicht nicht mal mehr der heutigen jugend das stimmt ja eigentlich gar nicht so der
so der so der der suma generationen so im endeffekt früher waren world of warcraft so das ultra
hype game was jeder gespielt hat so sag mal so meine meine generation ja und minecraft ist so
dass das der 15 bis 25 generationen also sagen wir so der 25 sagen wir so der 30 bis 40 generationen
oder ja ist es ist es ist es warcraft world of warcraft und jetzt die der generationale minecraft
if you counted each view is just a single second the total time that would make up would be 30,000
years undoubtedly the games wild popularity has turned out to be a smart investment for
microsoft to purchase the developer of the game mojang for two and a half billion dollars back
in 2014 square enix has temporarily pulled final fantasy was habe ich auch warum eigentlich
die unable to buy just the game weil die warte schlagen so lange waren oder register for any
free trials the company decided to take these drastic measures following the release of the
mmo's recent endwalker expansion it's been so popular that the servers are still struggling
das musste erst mal schaffen das spiele ich so erfolgreich dass jetzt der verkauf eingestellt
wird up with all the new players that it brought on in the two weeks after launch the current
advertisement for endwalker will go on hiatus but square enix confirmed it would not suspend all
marketing plans to help make up for the outages and pulling the game from sale free accounts
will get their playable time increased that's it that's it blizzard auch gerne mal wieder bei
dem game 21 before we get to our final story können die nicht neue server hinstellen können
sich bei amazon auch neue server mieten let us know what games you've been playing the most during
the holiday season for me gut das bringt ja nix auf dem neuen server muss ja neues neue characters
erstellen und es dauert ja in final fantasy irgendwie 500 stunden bis du da auf max level
bist it's been half battlefield 2042 half diablo 2 resurrected which i am still addicted to and a
little bit of townscaper when i just need to chill 343 studios address concerns expressed by
players during its tenry event the big complaint is just how much of the available event content
is stuck behind a paywall instead of being earnable through game play ich spiele immer
noch regelmäßig halo aber das mit dem season pass also der progress ist unglaublich langsam
und das event macht keinen spaß design jerry hook so man die ist die brauchen noch gar keine
eigenen server komponenten die können sich doch bei microsoft amazon oder google was mieten
from a communication mistake he addressed the issues in a community stream and promised better
clarity about which items are earnable and which items will be purchasable 343 are also looking to
add more event wollen die aber nicht an sind sie dumm wenn sie das nicht wollen sind sie blöd da
müssen sie halt auf kohle verzichten warts this is also part of an initiative that 343 has
already slowly started implementing to improve the challenge system since launch they've added new
challenges die wollte mir wirklich erzählen leute ich habe keine ahnung ich glaube euch das jetzt
einfach chat wollte mir wirklich erzählen final fantasy die wir auch immer das betreibt dahinter
infrastruktur nicht die betreiben ihre server wirklich noch selber die haben das doch garantiert
bei jedem cloud anbieter die haben doch da kein eigenes rechenzentrum für die können die server
bei hetzner zum beispiel betreiben soll sie ich kann ihnen auch in 20 euro startgutschein vermitteln
die haben die haben das doch garantiert in englischer cloud laufen niemand hat mehr eigene
rechenzentren angebunden über irgendeine fritzbox wahrscheinlich noch ja von wie vielen spielern
reden wir was was ich was hat was hat final fantasy für spieler drei millionen vier millionen
5 millionen natürlich nicht gleichzeitig aktive accounts oder erstellte account oder ich weiß
gar nicht wie die das wie die das waren keine ahnung aber es ist sony ich mein sony hat das
selbst genug ne es ist nicht sony schwachsinn square enix hat mit sony nichts zu tun oder
ne es ist nicht ist nicht sony keine ahnung aber gut dann dann muss man halt auf kohle verzichten
sp for completing matches they've also reworked some of the harder challenges to be more accessible
and that wraps it up for this weekend gaming as always guys thank you so much for watching
okay sollen wir das jetzt danach gucken die ultimate battlefield 2042 tactics tierlist
soll angeblich ein gutes video sein wurde auch schon im chat empfohlen gucken wir jetzt
hallo again von ks alter welcome back gentlemen sehr gut half life sounds da kann das video
nur was taugen jala dankeschön mich was das many als das komplette game ist
gaffed to us here but before we get into the list you must be curious about my opinion
on the game itself well i think many of us would be in agreement yes the game is broken
yes the game is unfinished and yes it probably should have been delayed but an experienced
bean beret such as yourself will not see this as a bad thing in this chaos you will see
opportunity you will see things that can be exploited them and today we will be doing
exactly that so let us begin
and starting us off once again we have the long range sniper sagt last video these guys
richtig das sagt es gibt in diesem spiel noch mehr als in jedem anderen battlefield
die am arsch der welt rumliegen und schreibern und nichts killen und du kannst nichts dagegen
machen
if i go ahead and search longer each night fit my youtube comments you'll see a bunch
of whiney bitches claiming that it's about aim and then they came here's how well the
snipers technically in the backline because that's what they do everything yeah battlefield
just like real life give me a fucking break no using a sniper after this game is actually
quite fun so i would choose to go away way beyond what is a reasonable range is completely
beyond me you can't even spot people at that distance and you don't even get a bonus
Ich habe ihn in die Hände geschossen.
Ja, so ist richtig.
Sniper-Rots.
Raid! Shadow Legends! Ich habe keinen Witz.
Dieses Video wird von Raid gesponsert.
Ist das ein Fake?
Shadow Legends.
Das größte RPG-PvP-Mobile-Game, das in der Welt existiert.
Raid! Shadow Legends.
Es gibt eine ganze Menge angenehme, angenehme Leute.
Das ist wirklich gesponsert.
Ich dachte, der will uns jetzt verarschen.
Er hat gesagt, I'm not joking.
Ich dachte, das ist Meta-Joke.
Er sagt, I'm not joking, dass man besonders denkt, er joggt.
Das ist wirklich lame.
Das ist wirklich lame in 2042.
Das bisschen, was es da in Evolution gibt.
Und wisst ihr noch in dem Trailer,
wo man gesehen hat, wie aus dem Schiff die Wand rausfällt
und alle rennen weg
ohne Staupen.
Sieht übel spektakulär aus.
Und im Endeffekt gibt es das zwar im Spiel,
aber es sieht kacke aus.
Tentenetow
Incredible
Sponsor und es fällt nach unten
Halt diese Zeichen
Blut sie hoch und sie fallen nach unten
Oh
Die Seite der Schiffe
Ja das sieht so schlecht aus
Guck mal richtig lame
Das ist 8 Jahre alt und auch
Verletzt in einer komplett Buggys
Und dieses Spiel hat einfach
Das
Ja das, das sieht schon ziemlich armselig aus
Vergleich zu BF4
Man muss sich ja auch mal angucken
Wie sehr du Maps wie Grand Bazaar
Die Wände in die Luft springen
Konntest. Du konntest in Grand Bazaar
Zwar nicht tragende Strukturen und die Map
Richtig selbst kaputt machen
Aber du konntest in Grand Bazaar die ganzen Häuserwände
Einsprengen und sowas. Das ist mehr
Zerstörung als es
Auf den meisten Battlefield 2042
Maps insgesamt gibt
Du musst bedenken es ist Corona
Diese Begründung habe ich schon oft gehört
Auch wenn es Chibate ist im Chat
Aber Corona ist da keine Ausrede zu
Ich kenne das Video wo
Der Tom Henderson erzählt was die eigentlich
Für Probleme hatten und ja ich kann das auch als
Entwickler oder Programmierer nachvollziehen
Aber das Management muss das lösen
Dafür sind die da, dafür kriegen die Millionen
Dafür kriegen die ihr Geld
Um so eine Scheiße zu lösen
Und das haben sie nicht gemacht
Weiterer Punkt wo man es verkackt hat
MonkaS warum schreit er denn jetzt so
Ja und dann fliegt das
Quer über die Map
Ja und das funktioniert jetzt nicht im Spiel
Weil man sich gedacht hat
Ein weiterer Punkt den ich
Der mir wirklich wirklich
Extrem auf den Sack geht
Ist dieses Chibate gewesen in den Trailern
Um Veteranen und quasi
Ältere Battlefield Fans anzusprechen
Von Dogtags
Bis Rausspringen
Aus dem Flugzeug
Und Schießen
Bis zu dem Base Jump
Bis zu dem, das war einfach nur um
Battlefield Rep Veteranen zu hypen
Und zum Kauf zu verleiten weil sie genau wussten
Wenn erstmal rauskommt
In was für einem Scheiß
Zustand dieses Spiel ist
Wird von diesen Spielern niemals irgendjemand
Dieses Spiel kaufen
Deswegen musste man sie gleich catchen die Leute
Von denen man wusste sie bekommen nie wieder
Geld von denen
Zu Recht
Na was kommt jetzt
Ja Hazard Zone ist ja der größte Witz überhaupt
Hazard Zone ist so ein unsinniges Ding
Das hat überhaupt keine Daseinsberechtigung
In diesem Spiel überhaupt warum ist das überhaupt drinnen
Das ist vom Ansatz her vielleicht
Echt ein sinniger Spielmodus
Aber jetzt in der Form
Es ist einfach ein so
Das ist Hazard Zone wirkt wie ein Spielmodus
Den jemand in so einem
Wochenende Modding Competition
Irgendwo erstellt hat
Das ist auch richtig langweilig
Zu spielen
Ich habe das
Wir haben das mal ein Nachmittag gespielt
Weil ich ein bisschen Videomaterial gebraucht habe
Und es ist einfach nur
Langeweile pur es sind zu wenig Spieler
Du hast ja glaube nur
32 Spieler
Oder so
Total wenig
Du hast die riesengroßen Maps
Du hast komische Bots es passiert eigentlich nichts
Der Jeep ist OP er ist fuck
Es ist einfach nur dumm
Es ist unsinnig dass es überhaupt vorhanden ist
Ich verstehe es nicht
Hazard Zone ist ein weiterer
Scheiß will auch keiner mehr spielen
Hazard Zone ist ein weiteres Beispiel dafür
Was in der Entwicklung von diesem Spiel schief gelaufen ist
Dass das angefangen hat
Als so eine Sorte Game umgewurschtet wurde
Wir haben es in dem Video von Tom Henderson gesehen
Wie viel da sich in der Entwicklung getan hat
Und im Prinzip nur in eineinhalb Jahren
Da das restliche Spiel zusammen geschustert wurde
Genau so fühlt es sich auch an
Ja aber das ist total
Das ist richtig Müll
Ich habe es auch mal versucht ein bisschen zu spielen
Das ist richtig Müll, eigentlich finde ich die Idee
Dass man einen Hacker-Man im Spiel hat
Was Richtung Sombra von Overwatch
Eigentlich ganz cool, aber das dauert zu lang
Und es passiert kaum was
Wenn du die Dinger gehackt hast
Ich glaube die können nicht schießen
Oder das HUD ist disabelt oder irgendwie sowas
Aber die Leute, die Fahrzeuge können einfach wegfahren
Ja, aber das bringt nichts
Das dauert viel zu lang
Chats sagt man bekommt nicht mal Punkte dafür
Ja du bekommst in diesem Spiel
Ja für nichts wirklich Punkte
Du bekommst für Kills Punkte, du bekommst für Assists
Ja, aber irgendwelche coole Aktionen gemacht
Points Deck, der hochkaut
Nö, gibt's nicht
Und es fliegt weg
Das ist einfach so eine heftige Enttäuschung
Das Spiel
Jetzt nachdem das ein Monat raus ist
Wird mir immer mehr klar an wieviel Stellen
Das Spiel eigentlich eine Enttäuschung
Und was ich immer ganz grausam finde
Ist die Leute, das ist ja auch bei mir in den Kommentaren
Auf YouTube so nach dem Motto
Oh Max, hör doch mal auf das Spiel zu kritisieren
Ich hab da meinen Spaß dran oder irgendwie sowas
Mein Gott ey, es ist doch schön
Wenn die Leute ihren Modus anwenden
Und das Spiel einfach einfach
Mein Gott ey, es ist doch schön
Wenn die Leute ihren Spaß dran haben
Aber bin ich jetzt das Problem
Dass ich sage, dass das Spiel kacke ist
Oder die Leute das Spiel kacke entwickelt haben
Das ist wie wenn die Leute im Mittelalter
Den Boote
Erschossen haben
Ich verstehe das nicht
Es gibt immer noch Leute, die das Ultra verteidigen
Wenn sie den Fanboy Award von DICE gewinnen
Ich sag euch wie es ist
DICE ist einfach ein unfähiger Kackehaufen mittlerweile
Ich bin richtig
Wie sagt man so schön
Salty und getriggert und getiltet und was auch immer
Die sind so unfähig
Ich dachte ja es ist vorgeschoben
Dass die gesagt haben vor ein paar Jahren
Die haben vor ein paar Jahren gesagt
Sie können kein Bad Company 3 machen
Sie wissen gar nicht mehr
Was Bad Company eigentlich gut gemacht hat
Und da habe ich mir gedacht
Okay ihr labert doch bloß rum
Fragt einfach mal ein paar Fans
Spielt das alte Spiel
Ihr kommt da schon wieder drauf
Und außerdem ist es eh nur vorgeschoben
Weil ihr aus irgendwelchen Gründen kein Bad Company 3 machen wollt
Aber mittlerweile muss ich sagen
Nein das war die Wahrheit
Die haben wirklich absolut
Keinen
Plassen Schimmer mehr
Was Bad Company gut gemacht hat
Und die sind auch geistig anscheinend nicht dazu
In der Lage
Sich rein zu versetzen
Was könnten denn die Spieler
An diesem Spiel gemocht haben
Weil wären sie in der Lage
Dann hätten sie ja auch
Darauf Sachen auf Battlefield 2042
Anwenden können
Aber sie sind nicht in der Lage
Und ich wette mit euch
Die spielen zum größten Teil ihren eigenen
Scheiß nicht
Ich habe es gesehen
Ich war bei diesem einen Event dabei
Wisst ihr was die Leute gemacht haben
Das ist die Wahrheit
Ich kann es euch nicht beweisen
Aber ich war bei diesem Event dabei
Wisst ihr was
Ich weiß nicht ob es alle waren
Aber demjenigen von DICE
Den ich im Stream zugeguckt habe
Wisst ihr was der gemacht hat
Wie der Battlefield 2042 gespielt hat
Das ist kein Witz
Der stand in Orbital oben auf dem Tower
Und hat seine Drohne zephiert
Das ganze Game
Der hat das Spiel nicht gespielt
Der hat die ganze Zeit seine Drohne zephiert
In dem Briefview Event
Der hat nicht
Gescheit gespielt
Ah
Die spielen das Spiel nicht
Die wissen nicht was das Spiel ausmacht
Was es gut macht
Was die alten Spiele gut gibt
Die haben keinen Plan mehr
Das kann man sich das auch nicht erklären
Und dazu kommt EA noch
Was es sicherlich nicht besser gemacht hat
Und die haben
Die haben sicherlich
Die haben sicherlich Leute
Die da noch
Bisschen Gespür für haben
Und die dann auch noch ein bisschen
Ein gutes Battlefield machen
100% haben die noch
Aber auf die hört man nicht
Und ich sage nicht mal, dass EA nicht auf die hört
Nein, auch schon die oberen Führungsleute
Bei DICE werden da nicht drauf hören
Das was dort entschieden wird
Und gemacht wird geht komplett an dem vorbei
Was die Spieler sich wünschen von einem Battlefield
Und ja du kannst nicht
Da bin ich der erste der das auch zugibt
Du kannst nicht bei jedem Scheiß auf die Spieler hören
90% der Spieler sind
Kacke und Sacken in dem Game
Wenn du auf die hörst mit das Spiel schlechter
Das ist aber auch die Aufgabe
Als
Design Director und was auch immer
Da gute Sachen
Rauszufiltern und auch
Ein bisschen dieses Gespür dafür zu haben
Feedback von den Leuten
Hat Hand und Fuß und das andere ist einfach nur
Rumgeheule Dafür ist ja so ein
Design Typ
Und Regisseur und was auch immer das alles gibt
Ist ja dafür da
Aber dann kriegen die das nicht gebacken
Dabei wäre das
Gar nicht so schwierig gewesen
Wenn man wirklich hätte wissen
Wollen wie das Spiel ankommt
Du hättest ohne Probleme
Battlefield Leute gefunden die gut in dem Spiel
Sind die
Auch kostenlos wahrscheinlich
Sogar bereit gewesen wären
Stunden in dieses Spiel
In der Entwicklung zu stecken und DICE
Sinnvolles Feedback zu geben
Kostenlos wahrscheinlich sogar das hätten die Leute
Freiwillig gemacht Man hätte auch gute
Spiele aus anderen Spielen einladen können
Und sagen Hey was sagt ihr denn
Die hätten beispielsweise mal wirklich gute
Nennen wir es mal Apex Spieler
Da haben sie doch um die Ecke
Haben sie doch Apex am Start
Gute Apex Spieler Gute PUBG Spieler
Gute Warzone Spieler hätten die doch mal
Einladen können und sagen Hey Leute
Wir haben da so einen neuen Modus
Designed Hazard Zone
Oder Work in Progress
Neuer Modus der sich ein bisschen an solche
Spiele anlehnt
Spielt mal eine Woche und gibt uns
Feedback
Ehrliches Feedback
Und dann wäre als Feedback rausgesprungen
Dieser Modus ist Bullshit
Aber haben sie nicht gemacht
Sie haben sich entweder eingeredet
So nach dem Motto Ja ist ja alles super
Das beste was wir je entwickelt haben
Und wir sind so Proud darauf dieses Spiel jetzt rauszumachen
Das ist der geilste Modus aller Zeiten
Hätten die sich mal wirklich Spieler geholt
Die Ahnung haben von dem
Von diesem Spielegenre
Da wäre das Fazit gewesen
Das ist einfach abgrundtiefe Krütze
So und das
Haben sie nicht gemacht
Wahrscheinlich weil sie sich selbst nicht eingestehen
Wollen dass es Müll ist
Und ganz ehrlich
Die meisten Content Creator
Die kannst du nicht fragen das funktioniert nicht
Ich hab das in diesem
Preview Event erlebt
Ich hab das sogar jetzt in meinem abschließenden Feedback
Noch mal hingeschrieben
Wobei das da wahrscheinlich keinen interessieren wird
Die meisten Content Creator
Sind einfach englischsprachig
Englischsprachig, für Deutschen keine Ahnung
Aber wahrscheinlich ist das da teilweise auch so
Aber gerade im englischsprachigen
Das sind Arschkriecher hoch 10
Wenn ihr mitgekriegt hättet
Wieder rumgeschleimt wurde
Das war der Meinung sie haben das beste Spiel
Seit der Erfindung des Rats
Seit geschnitten im Brot
gemacht
Nach diesem Feedback der englischsprachigen
Content Creators
Dort haben die sich überschlagen
Das sind solche Arschkriecher
Alles
Aber gut, früher Infos
Equals mehr Views
Mehr YouTube Stonks
Und sonst was
Unglaublich
Dieses Spiel ist so versagen
Auf so vielen Ebenen
Da fällt mir gar nichts mehr zu ein
Ja, genau
Ich glaube ich hab nicht einmal einen AT-Mine geworfen
In diesem Spiel
Hat mal jemand, jetzt mal ernsthaft
Wurde jemand mal von einem Repair Tool
Repariert in diesem Spiel
Jetzt mal Hand aufs Herz
Ehrlich, ehrlich, hat euch mal jemals einer
Wusstet ihr, also erstens
Wusstet ihr, dass das Repair Tool überhaupt in dem Spiel ist
Und wusstet, und wurdet ihr mal repariert
Ja
Das Spiel, ja das Spiel
Hat einen Repair Tool, glaube ich
Ich hab selbst noch nie ausgerüstet
Oh man
Niemals
Denkt ihr
Armor Plates
Ja, ganz ehrlich
Ich verstehe den Sinn von Armor Plates nicht
Es versaut die Time To Kill
Du weißt manchmal nicht was Sache ist
Dich selbst rettet es in denselben
Punkten und diese
Wir schieben uns die Platte rein Animation
Sieht aus wie Straight aus Warzone
Gerippt, guckt euch das mal an
Armor Plates
Guck mal
Das sieht original aus wie die Amazon
Alter, wie die Animation
Aus Warzone gerippt
Oder eben aus Firestorm
Warzone
Ja, ja ist ja gut
Weil Warzone Geld macht
Und die Leute nicht mehr in der Lage sind eigene
Spiele zu entwickeln, zu entwerfen
Und sich zu überlegen und da was
Raus zu machen
Ihr spielt eigentlich mal einen Soundtrack
Genau
Das hat keinen Soundtrack
Das hat
So ungefähr hört sich der Soundtrack
An vor Battlefield 2042
Wenn ich meinen Heizlüfter
Im Bad anmache, weil es mich friert
Das hört sich an wie der Battlefield Soundtrack
Ja, das macht ja kein Damages Zeug
Außer die Sniper
Außer die Sniper, die irgendwie
Helis two-hitten konnte
Oder sowas
Ja, das macht ja kein Damages Zeug
Außer die Sniper
Außer die Sniper, die irgendwie
Helis two-hitten konnte
Oder sowas
Warum soll ich meine Werbevideos zurücknehmen?
Dann krieg ich ja kein Geld
Außerdem hab ich unterschrieben, dass ich Werbevideos mache
Mache
Das geht nicht so einfach
Ich hab sogar nach dem zweiten Werbevideo
Bei der Agentur, über die ich das gemacht habe
gefragt, wollt ihr wirklich, dass ich das dritte Video noch hochlade?
Und ich wollten
Was soll ich dann machen?
Hehehehehehe
Ich hab keine
gesponserten Reviews hochgeladen
von dem Spiel
Ich hab drei Videos hochgeladen
Ich hab ein
Portal Video hochgeladen
Wo ich den Editor gezeigt hab
Das war sogar relativ gut das Video, unabhängig davon
Der Rules Editor ist auch eine coole Sache
Man kann sich aber das Spiel
viel beschweren, aber das ist wirklich gut, was sie da gemacht haben
Ähm
Dann hab ich
einen Gesamtüberblick hochgeladen
So nach dem Motto
Die drei Sachen gibt's
Und dann hab ich ein Hazard Zone Video gemacht
Ich hab keinen gesponserten Review hochgeladen
Ihr glaubt doch nicht ernsthaft, dass dieses Video
gesponsert war
Also mein Battlefield, mein Review zu dem Spiel
war ja im Endeffekt das hier
Ist das noch Battlefield, der Absturz von Battlefield
Ihr glaubt doch nicht, dass das gesponsert war
Also
Dann hätten die ja komplett jegliches Gehirn verloren
Wenn das gesponsertes Video gewesen sein soll
Ne ne, das war kein gesponsertes Video
Natürlich nicht. Das war gesponsert
Hazard Zone war gesponsert
Ähm
Die Übersicht war gesponsert
Und Portal war gesponsert
Steht auch überall drinne
Der Rest äh
Nicht. Und hier nach dem Video
Wollte ich das hochgeladen. Hier hab ich sogar extra
noch mal gefragt. Seid ihr euch sicher
Guck mal, das ist auch das einzige Video, was nicht mal ein Thumbnail
von mir gekriegt hat
Dass ich das wirklich hochladen soll
Ja und die meinten, ja ja mach
Ja
Tja
Einfach nicht annehmen, ja nachher
Das sagt sich im Nachhinein so einfach
Woher willst du das denn wissen
Du hast doch keine Ahnung
Zu dem Zeitpunkt davon
Dann dürftest du nie irgendwas annehmen
Vor allem haben die englischsprachigen
Channels sich lange
sehr zurückgehalten mit Kritik zu dem Video
Gibt es keinen Ausweg
Doch, natürlich. Du könntest
immer noch sagen, mach ich einfach nicht
Und am Endeffekt verklagen
tut dich eh keiner
Ob dann diese Agentur
noch mal jemand was
mit dir macht oder jemand anderes dahingestellt
Aber ich finde es keine
gute
wie soll ich sagen
Geschäftspraxis bei irgendwas zu
zu sagen und dann einseitig zu entscheiden
mach ich nicht
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen
wenigstens hab ich jetzt ein bisschen was mit diesem Scheißgame verdient
Da bin ich insofern eigentlich ganz froh drüber
Das Spiel hat mir so viel Nerven gekostet
Wenigstens hab ich ein bisschen Kohle gemacht
damit. Amazing, denke ich, für den Sub
Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass
irgendjemand das nicht erkannt hat, dass das Werbung ist
Das ist wie zu sagen, Alter, warum hat Michael Schumacher
Werbung gemacht für
Was hat der Werbung gemacht? Keine Ahnung
Für Dinger
So
Valburo, echt?
Weil sowas in der Regel
Das kann ich jetzt an der Stelle vielleicht auch mal erzählen
gemacht wird, bevor
das Spiel rauskommt
Weil da hängt ja
eine gewisse
Planung und Marketing Kampagne
hinten dran
Und das wird gemacht
meistens Wochen, wenn nicht
teilweise sogar schon Monate
zumindest in die Wege geleitet
bevor das Spiel eigentlich rauskommt
Und was willst du machen im Endeffekt?
Du kannst sagen, mach ich nicht
Da kannst du wahrscheinlich nie irgendwas machen
Das ist ja nicht so, dass ich das oft machen würde
Allgemein, ich mein, wenn ich mal Sponsored-Video mache
Das kannst du ja an einer
Hand abzählen
Sonst kannst du im Endeffekt
auch gar nichts machen
Du enables den Hype
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich so großartig den Hype
enabled hab
Ob mein meistgesehenes
Battlefield, wie du in letzter Zeit so den Hype
enabled hat, weiß ich nicht
Und das hier
Guck mal, das erste, was ich gemacht habe
war ein Video
zum Release
Und ich musste eindrücken, das war schon nicht
sondern nicht positiv
Danach hab ich zwei, drei gesponserte Videos gemacht
Und wir müssen jetzt auch mal ehrlich sein
Die Leute können halt auch mal gefälligst für sich denken
Wenn ich ein Video hochlade, wo ich sage
Das und das hier ist in dem Spiel
dieses Video ist gesponsert bei EA
Also, da kann ich erwarten, dass die Leute in der Lage sind
selbst zu überlegen
Aha, glaube ich, in dem gesponserten
Videos alles ungefragt
Oder guck ich mir mal beispielsweise Steam-Bewertung
oder Metacritic-Bewertung an
Also irgendwas ist halt auch mal gut
Ich kann jetzt auch nicht für alle
Eventualitäten da irgendwie vorsorgen
Also ich seh da nichts
Verwerfliches dran, weil man klar sagt, dass das
gesponsert ist
So was zu machen, ansonsten müsstest du sagen
jegliches Sponsoring ist schlecht, aber dann
hast du in der heutigen Zeit auch
quasi keine hauptberuflichen
Content-Creator mehr, die das machen
Ja, das stimmt auch wieder
Leute, selbst zu überlegen, aber da kann ich auch nichts
Kann ich den Leuten auch nicht helfen
Ey, es ist
halt riesen Marketing-Hype
der funktioniert, ja, natürlich ist das so
Aber letztendlich
Ich bin froh, da ich schon ein bisschen
Kohle gemacht hab noch mit dem Game, wenn's mir so
in den Sack geht
Wenn das Game schon nicht gut ist, hab ich wenigstens ein bisschen
was dran verdient, ja
Zumal ich ja selbst auch gedacht hab, das kommt
ja noch dabei, ich hab ja selbst es nicht
für möglich gehalten, dass dieses Spiel so
beschissen wird, also so ultra beschissen
Ich hab mir vielleicht gedacht, hey
vielleicht wird das, vielleicht wird das
nicht
das allergeilste Battlefield überhaupt, ja
aber wer hätte denn sich
im Vorfeld gedacht
dass das so beschissen
wird
so ultra beschissen, so richtig
Hardcore beschissen, das
hätt ich nicht gedacht
Ja, da muss man halt vielleicht mal zwei
Meter weit denken, bei einem
gesponserten Video
Na, da
kannst du auch sagen, ja
vielleicht haben die Leute Geld verloren
weil sie sich diese komischen
wie rasiere ich meinen Sack richtig
Videos, Werbung angucken
auf YouTube, die gibt's ja zur Zeit auch, weiß ich ob ihr die kennt
Kennt ihr das, diese
Manshaving-Dings
Videos, die zur Zeit auch recht
beliebt sind auf YouTube, klar ey, vielleicht
hat sich auch einer davon was gekauft, weil es
beworben wurde, ja gut
So es ist halt bei Werbung
so
Kennt ihr die nicht?
Es gab ja noch bei der Beta, das war ja der Witz
Es gab ja noch bei der
Beta das Gerücht so nach dem
Motto, das kommt noch das Scoreboard
Da gibt's ja Leute, die haben das in der Beta schon
verteidigt, die haben gesagt
Leute, Leute, das ist nur eine Beta, das Scoreboard kommt
noch
Aber ja, das
ey, ich gämpfe mir ja insofern recht
das kann man durchaus so sehen, aber dann
kannst du keinerlei
also dann kannst du nirgendswo
mehr für irgendwas Werbung machen
und ich glaube, besser
Kennzeichen offensichtlicher machen, als
ich in dem Fall, kannst du das eigentlich kaum noch
und dann
müsstest du die jegliche Werbung überall
untersagen, kann man auch
machen, kann man auch machen, ja
Aber dann gibt es halt keinerlei
professionellen E-Sport mehr
Keinerlei professionelle Content Creator
mehr
Keinerlei professionellen Sport mehr
Da gibt es fast nichts mehr
wenn du Werbung und Sponsoring untersagst
Ja, ich fühle mich auch
ultra, ultra erniedrigt
durch das Scoreboard, ganz, ganz schrecklich
Leute, ich muss ja mal kurz was zu
trinken holen, bin gleich wieder, ich bin gleich wieder am Start
SICK
So, wieder da, was das Scoreboard ist
Hatespeech, Leute in der heutigen Zeit
kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass bei einigen
das Scoreboard schon als Hatespeech durchgeht
Weil in einem Scoreboard
zieht mehr das Leute vielleicht besser spielen als andere
Das geht ja auf gar keinen Fall
So
Gucken wir mal weiter
Backups, you are doing them wrong
Warum?
Ah ne, wir sind ja noch gar nicht fertig damit
Lul, Sekunde, wir haben ja die
Wo sind wir? Wir haben ja die
Tactic Liste noch gar nicht durchgeguckt
Ok
Was?
Das geht?
Das wusste ich gar nicht
Was ist das?
Das ist ja nice
Das wusste ich gar nicht, dass das geht
Das geht
Habt ihr das auf Twitch eigentlich mitbekommen?
Warum?
Vielleicht könnt ihr mir das erklären, ich check's nicht
Ich hab auf vielen Channels auf Twitch jetzt schon gesehen
Zum größten Teil
irgendwelche, sagen wir mal so ein bisschen
Meme-lastigere
Channels
die alle irgendwelche Furz-Sounds
im Hintergrund haben
Mit Channel-Commands und irgendwelchen
externen Seiten, wo du donaten kannst
für Furzgeräusche und sowas
Was ist denn da los?
Warum gibt es so viele Channels auf Twitch
mittlerweile, wo es Furzgeräusche
im Hintergrund gibt?
Was ist das für ein neues Twitch-Meter?
Ich hab gestern
Das war der Höhepunkt
Ich hab gestern irgendwie 2 Stunden
im Stream von einem geguckt, der World of Warcraft
Hardcore Moltencore-Rate gemacht hat
Und da hat's alle 5 Sekunden gefurzt
Nicht deutscher Humor
internationale Streams
Und wie gesagt, das war so der Höhepunkt
an Furz-Sounds
an Furz
per minutes, die ich in dem Stream gehört hab
in anderen Streams war es ein bisschen weniger
Aber warum ist das zurzeit auf Twitch so beliebt?
Deutschsprachige Channels
guck ich kaum
welche, keine Ahnung, ob das dort auch so ist
Also das irgendwie komisches neues Twitch-Meter
Ach um wen geht's?
Ah, Pyke
Pyke? Puck? Wie heißt die?
Pyke? Ich glaub Pyke oder so
Der Wallhack ist richtig sinnlos. Am Anfang dachte man auch, oh nein, Hilfe, OP Wallhack, aber es ist richtig für'n Arsch.
Zumal nicht alle killen damit. Die Leute sehen mich.
Wobei ich mir gar nicht sicher bin, ob das immer noch so ist.
Oh, Bots, bitte.
Ich meine, ein Vorteil haben die Bots in diesem Spiel.
Man muss das Spiel nicht länger in einem noch weniger spaßigen Zustand spielen, wie es eh schon ist.
Also, man kann seine Waffen relativ schnell anlocken, damit man nicht mit der SMG mit 20 Schuss rumrennen muss.
So, also dafür sind die Bots gut. Zum Beispiel das, was er macht hier auf Kaleidoskop, das ist zwar nicht der richtige Spot, aber ähnlich.
Auf Kaleidoskop einfach innerhalb von einer halben Stunde seine Waffe auf Max Attachments boosten.
Ja, Bots schotten dich manchmal.
Der Spot ist richtig sinnlos.
Der Spot ist gefixt, wirklich?
Ja, Bots schotten dich manchmal.